YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON WE'D LIKE
TO CALL THIS- COMMITTEE
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
ELECTRICITY PRICES TO ORDER
THIS IS- IMPORTANT TOPIC AND I
BELIEVE A VERY TIMELY ONE SO WE
HOPE THAT OUR PRESENTERS WE
EXPECT AND ANTICIPATE WILL BE
OF VERY INFORMATIVE IN HELPING
US TO FOCUS ON OF THE COST OF.
ELECTRICITY IN THE STATE AND
ITS IMPACT ON OUR RATE PAYERS
LET ME SAY GOOD AFTERNOON TO
ALL OF YOU INTO OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE AND
THOSE LISTENING OR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROCEEDING OF LET ME HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT OUR VICE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
START THE MEETING WITH THE VICE
CHAIR PRESENT- HE IS NOT ABLE
TO BE WITH US TODAY HE'S OUT IN
HIS DISTRICT ON BUSINESSES
AFTERNOON BUT SENDS HIS REGRETS
WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS WILL BE
JOINING US WE THINK IS THE KIND
OF TOPIC THAT MOST MEMBERS HAVE
RESPONDED TO VERY FAVORABLY SO
WE ANTICIPATE- AS PAUL KNOW HOW
THE COMING AND GOING OF. OF
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES AROUND THE
CAPITAL WILL FORCE MEMBERS TO
HAVE TO LEAVE OR COME A LITTLE
LATE BUT WE'RE ANTICIPATING
FULL PARTICIPANT XIN. A HOLDING
THIS. HEARING A TO HIGHLIGHT
THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
AFFORDABILITY OF ELECTRICITY
AND CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY. TO
ELECTRIFY SECTORS WITH HIDES.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF
TRANSPORTATION BUILDINGS COULD
OFFER THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
PATH. TO DEEP THE CARBONIZATION
A RECENT REPORT BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S WHO'S
WITH US TODAY CAUTIONS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S RATES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN MOST
OTHER STATES. HI ELECTRICITY
PRICES COULD SLOW TRANSITION
AWAY FROM GASOLINE DIESEL AND
NATURAL GAS OF THE COSTA POWER
ELECTRICAL ALTERNATIVES BECOMES
PROHIBITIVE. OVER THE LAST
DECADE THE ANNUAL EMISSIONS
FROM THE ELECTRIC SECTOR HAVE
DECLINED BY ABOUT FORTY MILLION
METRIC TONS OR 40% THOSE
REDUCTIONS HAVE BEEN THE
PRIMARY DRIVER OF STATEWIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS FROM THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR WHICH IS APPROXIMATELY
15% OF CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL
EMISSIONS. DECLINING PRICES THE
RENEWABLES ARE PROVIDING THE
MEANS TO THE CARBON EYES THE
ELECTRIC SECTOR AND
CORRESPONDINGLY SECTORS WHICH
MUCH HIGHER. EMISSIONS PROFILE
SUCH AS THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR AND RESIDENTIAL. HOWEVER
THERE HAVE BEEN THERE HAS BEEN
A DISTURBING DISTURBING
INCREASE IN ELECTRICITY RATES
BEYOND THE RATE OF INFLATION IN
THE RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL SECTORS CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTRICITY PRICES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN MOST
OTHER STATES. RETAIL
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE HIGHER
DUE TO A VARIETY OF FACTORS
INCLUDING THE DECLINING
ELECTRICITY CONSUMPTION AND
COSTS FOR VARIOUS STATE
MANDATED PROGRAMS THAT ARE
EMBEDDED ELECTRICITY RATES.
DECLINING CONSUMPTION EQUATES
TO FIX COST BEING SPREAD OVER A
SMALLER BASE OF CUSTOMERS.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS PER
PRECIPITATING INCREASES IN
ELECTRICITY RATES AND WHAT
ACTIONS WE CAN TAKE TO REVERSE
THE UPWARD TREND IS VITAL. IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS
THAT INCREASE ELECTRICITY
PRICES HAVE ON RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS AND OUR
ABILITY TO ACHIEVE OUR CRITICAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOALS.
THROUGH GREATER ELECTRIFICATION.
THE WITNESSES WE HAVE COMING
FOR BEFORE US TODAY ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO ADDRESS THESE
CRITICAL ISSUES. LET ME FIRST-
TURN TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- TO SEE IF THEY WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS BEFORE I CALL THE
PANEL FORWARD- BUT I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. WE TAKE
THIS ISSUE UP EARLY AT OUR
SESSION BECAUSE AS WE LOOK AT
LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT IT
WITH AN UNDERSTANDING OF ITS
IMPACT ON RATE PAYERS BECAUSE I
THINK AS WE'VE HEARD. AND
HERBAL HOUSING OF SIDE OF THE
WORLD THE RENTS ARE TOO DARN
HIGH. THAT'S MY EDIT. THE
ELECTRICITY PRICES ARE TOO DARN
HIGH. AND SO IF- THERE ANY
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AN
OPENING COMMENT I'LL TURN TO
THEM NOW. THIS RACE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR ELEVATING THE ISSUE
ELECTRICITY RATES AND FOR
ORGANIZING THIS HEARING. AS YOU
NOTED MISTER CHAIR IN THE
RECENT. LA REPORT ON THE
ELECTRICITY GENERATION IT'S
MADE CLEAR THAT THESE HIGH
UTILITY RATES AND PRICES ARE
GOING TO BE A BARRIER FOR
FUTURE EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. R.
G. H. G. TOOK TARGETS ARE VERY
AMBITIOUS AND IT'S CRITICAL
THAT IS A STATE WE MEET OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS. AS THESE
UTILITY RATES INCREASE THAT
LIKELIHOOD DECREASES DURING OUR
LAST HEARING THE CPUC PRESIDENT
TO MERRY BELL BOETTCHER. STATED
THAT FOR EVERY BILLION AND
WHILE FARM WITH WILD FIRE
MITIGATION COST RATE PAYER
RATES WILL INCREASE BY 7%
THAT'S FRIGHTENING. NOT ONLY
THAT BUT UTILITIES RATES HAVE
ALSO BEEN GOING UP FASTER THAN
INFLATION. ACCORDING TO THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
RESIDENTIAL RATES HAVE RISEN.
31% BETWEEN TWO TWO THOUSAND
NINE AND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
HIGHER THAN THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX OF 19% LAST YEAR WE VOTED
AND POUNCED. AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
TRUST IN THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
GOVERNMENT TO. HOLD THE PGA ANY
TO THEIR END OF THE BARGAIN. I
KNOW THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS
ARE NOT EASY BUT WE HAVE TO
FIND MIDDLE GROUND ONE THAT
INSURERS WE CAN MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND ONE THAT DOES
NOT BURDEN OUR RATE PAYERS I
LOOK FORWARD TO TODAY'S
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU DOCTOR
QUIRK. I'M GOING TO SOUND A
LITTLE BIT LIKE A SKEPTICAL
REPUBLICAN ON THIS BUT- LOOK
THE C. E. C. DECIDED AWHILE
AGO. THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
DEMAND ROOFTOP SOLAR. ON NEW
BUILDINGS AND I THINK THAT WAS
A MISTAKE. IT IS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN SIMPLY WHAT
WE'RE PLANNING TO DO ANYWAY
WHICH IS TO HAVE FAILED- WELL
FOR TROUT THERE'S ALREADY
MANDATE. TO GO A 100% RENEWABLE
WE DON'T REALLY NEED TO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL MANDATE. AND ROOFTOP
SOLAR SIMPLY MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN HAVING A SOLAR
FARM- IT'S SEVERAL TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE. FURTHER YOU THEN
HAVE THE PEOPLE ARE BUYING NEW
HOMES BY AND- MUCH MORE- HIGH
INCOME THAN THE AVERAGE PERSON
GETTING A BREAK ON THE FACT
THAT THEY HAVE SOLAR. AND
THAT'S BEING PAID FOR OUT OF
THE GENERAL RATE CASE. I CAN'T
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW MUCH
THAT IS BUT I WILL BE ASKING
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATES WILL COME
UP HERE TO LOOK INTO THAT
BECAUSE IT IS INCREASING COST.
A SECOND THING WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE DOING A LOT OF ENERGY
CONSERVATION BURKE WORK ON
BUILDINGS AND YET. WHEN WE LOOK
AT THAT WORK IT DOESN'T PAY
OFF. IT SIMPLY DOESN'T RESEARCH
HAS BEEN DONE AT UC BERKELEY AM
I T. AND CHICAGO. AS WELL AS
OUR REPORTS DONE HERE WHICH
I'VE LOOKED AT IN THE PAST I
DIDN'T COME PREPARED TO BRING
ALL THOSE REPORTS WITH ME BUT I
COULD- WHICH SIMPLY SHOW. THAT
THE ESTIMATES OF. ARE NOT AT
ALL CLOSE TO THE ACTUAL SAVINGS
IN THE ACTUAL SAVINGS ARE
SEVERAL TIMES LESS BILL FOR
ELECTRIC AND GAS USAGE. SO
WE'RE JUST NOT SPENDING OUR
MONEY RIGHT AND IF WE'RE GOING
TO ACHIEVE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
GOALS WE REALLY OUGHT TO
RETRIEVE THEM IN THE CHEAPEST
WAY POSSIBLE AND THAT DOESN'T
MEAN ROOFTOP SOLAR SHOULD BE
MANDATED. IT MEANS WE BUILT
MORE ENERGY FARMS AT SOLAR
ENERGY FARMS AND IF WE'RE GONNA
DO OUR ENERGY CONSERVATION WE
OUGHT TO UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH
MONEY IT ACTUALLY SAVES WE'RE
SPENDING BILLIONS ON THAT AND
IT'S NOT GETTING THE PAY OFF. I
CAN'T TELL YOU WHY BUT THE
NUMBERS ARE THERE AND IT'S NOT
SO. THERE IT IS. THANK YOU. OUR
WILL IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
OPENING THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS TO
BE SHARED WILL TURN TO OUR
PANEL. AND I LIKE TO CALL
FORWARD ROSS BROWN WITH THE
OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
WILL GO FIRST DR JAMES.
BUSHNELL PROFESSOR AT
DEPARTMENT OF ECONOMICS
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
LINDA SERIZAWA. DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ENERGY OFFICE OF THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE. AND SCOTT KREIDER
VICE PRESIDENT CUSTOMER SERVICE
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC WHEN
A WELCOME ALL OF YOU. AND WE'LL
TURN TO YOU MISTER BROWN TO
START OUR CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS
BROWN AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. TODAY I'M
JUST GONNA OFFER SOME HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS AND SOME SUMMARY
COMMENTS BASED ON SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE DID IN THE REPORT
THAT YOU REFERENCED EARLIER
MISTER CHAIR THAT WE RELEASED
IN JANUARY WHAT'S REALLY THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF THAT REPORT
WAS ASSESSING KIND OF WHAT WE
KNOW AND DON'T NOW ABOUT THE
AFFECTS OF THE STATE'S MAJOR
CLIMATE POLICIES IN THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR- AND I'LL BE
SPEAKING TO A JUST A PIECE OF
THAT- WHICH WE TOUCH ON TOWARDS
THE END OF THE REPORT. ON TO
SEE RATES- BUT AS WE CANNOT
START THIS DISCUSSION I JUST-
AGAIN SIR SUMMARIZING SOME OF
THE HIGH LEVEL CONTEXT WHICH I
THINK IS IMPORTANT FOR THIS
DISCUSSION- AS YOU MENTION
MISTER CHAIR ELECTRICITY HAS
BEEN THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF
EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN THE
STATES. AT THE STATE HAS MEDI
YOU TWENTY TWENTY GOAL A FEW
YEARS EARLY AND IF YOU LOOK
BACK OVER THE PAST DECADE OR SO
ESSENTIALLY KIND OF ALL OF
THOSE REDUCTIONS HAVE BEEN FROM
ELECTRICITY GENERATION- AND IN
PARTICULAR A CHANGES IN THE MIX
OF ELECTRICITY. SOURCES OF IS
TO GENERATE ELECTRICITY. NOW
WHEN YOU LOOK OUT TOWARDS THE
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS IN THE
BEYOND THAT THOSE. MORE AND SO-
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA REQUIRE
REDUCTIONS FROM OTHER SECTORS
BEYOND JUST ELECTRICITY AND
THAT'S WHY WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT-
EMISSION REDUCTIONS ACROSS
DIFFERENT SECTORS. YOU KNOW A
LECTURE CITY AS WELL AS
TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDINGS
AND IN PARTICULAR THIS QUESTION
OF. ELECTRIFICATION AND THAT
BEING ONE OF THE- POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS TO ACHIEVING SOME OF
THE MORE AMBITIOUS. REDUCTIONS
AND WHAT ROLE KIND OF OUR OUR
POLICIES ELECTRICITY SECTOR
PLAY AN INDYCAR NICE IN THOSE
OTHER SECTORS. AND THEN THAT
BRINGS US TO. THE ISSUE OF THE
HIGHLIGHT TRICITY RATES AND WE
DO THINK THAT IT COULD BE- ONE
BARRIER TO ACHIEVING THOSE MORE
AGGRESSIVE EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS. RATES ARE YOU'LL HEAR
FROM A PROFESSOR BUSH NOW ON
SOME OF THEIR GOOD WORK IN
LOOKING AT RATES AND
ELECTRICITY RATES BEING QUITE A
BIT HIGHER THAN. THE MARGINAL
COST OF PRODUCING ELECTRICITY
INCLUDING SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS
ASSOCIATED WITH. DOING THAT AND
WE THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION WHEN THINKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT. WHAT AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL FOR SORT OF A
RETAIL RATE ON TURN IN TERMS OF
CENTS PER KILOWATT HOUR IS. AND
HOW IT MIGHT SERVICE BARRIER TO
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THERE'S A
LOT OF REASONS WHY RATES RETAIL
RATES ARE HIGHER THAN OTHER
STATES AND HIGHER THAN SOCIAL
MARGINAL COST SOME OF THOSE.
THE BIG I THINK SOME OF THE BIG
POTENTIAL EXPLANATIONS ARE HOW
WE TREAT FIX COSTS INCLUDING
THOSE AND VOLUMETRIC
ELECTRICITY RATES. THE OTHER IS
STATE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES AND
THOSE ARE BUILT INTO BIOMETRIC
RATE SO WE DON'T HAVE A REALLY
CLEAR BREAKDOWN OF ALL THE
DIFFERET FACTORS AND AGREE TO
WHICH THEY CONTRIBUTE BUT-
THOSE ARE. SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT FACTORS- AND SNOW
THAT THE EFFECTS OF THOSE
HIGHER RATES- CAN HAVE ECONOMIC
AFFECTS YOUR DISCOURAGING
VALUABLE ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES
FROM BOTH HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES. BUT ALSO YOU KNOW
THE ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT US AND SERVING AS
A BARRIER TO ELECTRIFICATION
OF. ELECTRIC VEHICLES OR-
BUILDINGS IMPLANTS IS. SO I
THINK THE MOST CHALLENGING
ASPECT OF THIS ISSUE IS YOU
KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT- AND
YOU KNOW IT I THINK THERE'S
GENERALLY NOT A LOT OF EASY
ANSWERS SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS I THINK IN FRONT OF
YOU AS YOU. LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
I'M I THINK GENERALLY
ENCOURAGING RATE STRUCTURES
WHERE THE RETAIL RATE THAT A
CONSUMER BUSINESS FACES THAT
REFLECTS. THAT KIND OF MARGINAL
COST OF GENERATING THE
ELECTRICITY INCLUDING THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS IS KIND
OF A GOOD- OVERALL APPROACH AND
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW TO
SET RATES NOW THE CHALLENGE. IS
IF THE STATE MOVES IN THAT
DIRECTION THEY'RE ALL THESE
OTHER. COSTS RELATED TO FIX
COSTS FOR DISTRIBUTION AND
TRANSMISSION LINES AS WELL AS
STATE PROGRAM COSTS AND- IF YOU
DON'T INCLUDE THOSE IN THE
ELECTRICITY RATES THAN THAT
MONEY IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE.
RAISED IN SOME OTHER WAY AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU YOU FACE SOME
DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT HOW
TO DO THAT- YOU KNOW COUPLE THE
OPTIONS I THINK THAT YOU MIGHT
END UP HEARING ABOUT OUR- FIX
CHARGES. SO YOU KNOW. A CARD
XIN DOLLARS PER MONTH THAT IS
NOT BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY CONCERT YOU
CONSUME. IS KIND OF ON AVENUE
THAT I THINK YOU'LL HEAR A LOT
OF OTHER STATES. USE ANOTHER
UTILITIES USE TO CUT RECOVER
SOME OF THE FIXED COSTS SO THAT
WE THINK THAT'S- WORTH
EXPLORING THERE ARE TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATE WITH DOING THAT BUT
IT. IT'S WORTH EXPLORING. AND
THEN THE OTHER I THINK JUST
BROAD CATEGORY OF- KIND OF
SOLUTIONS ARE WORTH EXPLORING
AS- LOOKING AT OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES FOR SOME OF THE STATE.
PROGRAM COSTS AGAIN. THOSE
THERE'S NOT EASY ANSWERS THERE
AND THERE ARE CLEAR TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH USING OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES LIKE. CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS- AND SO YOU KNOW IT'S
GONNA TAKE A LOT OF KIND OF
CAREFUL AND THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION WHEN THOSE TRADE
OFFS- BUT WE DO THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO BE THINKING
ABOUT AND- AND LOOKING AND
STILL AND CONTINUING TO
EXPLORE. SO I'LL IN MY COMMENTS
THERE. WELL WE'LL HEAR FROM ALL
OF YOU AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK
WITH QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WANTS ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS REMAIN. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I I'M GONNA END UP
ECHOING A LOT OF WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN SENT BY ROSS AND SEVERAL
OF THE MEMBERS- SO I'LL LET ME
BE ABLE TOGO A LITTLE QUICKER.
SO I WAS GONNA TRY TO PUT THIS
IN THE CONTEXT OF CLIMATE
POLICY IN THE STATE- AS WE
WORRY HEARD THIS IS A GREAT
OVERSIMPLIFICATION BUT- TENSION
HE- DISTILLING DOWN THE CLIMATE
PLAN TO THESE TWO STEPS WERE
GOING TO TRY TO ZERO OR- PLEASE
TAKE. A LOT OF THE CARBON OUT
OF THE ELECTRICITY SECTOR- AND
THEN. TRY TO TRANSITION ALL
THESE OTHER SOURCES WHICH ARE
GOING TO BE HIGHER CARBON
INTENSIVE INTO ELECTRICITY
WHICH BY THEN WOULD BE.
RELATIVELY CLEAN RELATIVELY LOW
CARBON AND AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
THAT SORT OF THE MOST. DOMINANT
PARTS OF OUR CLIMATESTRATEGY.
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD WE'VE WE'VE
MADE GREAT STRIDES ON THE
ELECTRICITY SIDE- AND- WE'VE
ACHIEVED OUR TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS ALREADY THAT'S ALL COME
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY FROM
REDUCTIONS IN THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR- THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THE INDUSTRIAL AND
NATURAL GAS SECTOR THAT'S THE
GREEN AND YELLOW BARS THERE.
REALLY HAVEN'T- DECLINE MUCH IN
THE LAST DECADE AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO START
TO MAKE ME YOUR HEAD WILL PAY
IF WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET TO
OUR TWENTY THIRTY. ON GOALS. SO
THAT'S BACK THE CHALLENGES
WE'VE HEARD IS. REALLY STEP
ONE- AS WE PUSH MORE ON STEP
ONE IT MAKES STEP TO A PARTNER
WE ARE. ALL THE FIREMEN AND
OTHER POLICY CHOICES WE'VE
ALREADY ABOUT OF THEM. ARE
THEY'VE CONTINUE TO PUT UP
PRESSURE ELECT PRICES. ARE
PARTICULARLY VARIABLE ACTRESS
YOU PRICES ALL GET INTO- AND
THAT LEAVES US IN A WEIRD
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE ELECTRICITY
IS BY FAR THE CLEANEST OPTION
FOR OF FUEL. BUT IT'S ALSO FROM
A CONSUMER STANDPOINT BY FAR
THE MOST EXPENSIVE OPTION AND
SO IF WE'RE TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE. TO EMBRACE ELECTRICITY
AS A AS A- SOURCE OF FUEL FOR
OTHER SECTORS WERE REALLY SORT
OF. CREATING HEADWINDS FOR
OURSELVES BY MAKING IT VERY
COMMERCIALLY UNATTRACTIVE WITH
THESE PRICES. WHY ARE PRICES
HIGHER WE HAVE THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT THE MORE BUT I PUT THIS UP
HERE IT'S MUCH MORE. THAN I
HAVE TIME TO DESCRIBE THIS IS
FROM A COLLEAGUES ELECTRICITY
BILL WHERE. IT'S BROKEN OUT BY
SOME ROUGH SECTORS AND ONE OF
THE POINTS HERE IS THAT YOU CAN
SEE THE GREEN. RED BARS ARE
GROWING- OVER THE LAST HALF
DECADE THOSE ARE ESSENTIALLY
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS WHAT
ROSTER FOR TWO IS FIXED COSTS.
THESE ARE COSTS THAT DON'T GO
DOWN WHEN. PEOPLE OF. IT'S ALL
ARE ON THE ROOFTOPS OR DON'T GO
WHEN. CHARGING EVEY- THEY ARE A
CLASS OF CONNECTIVITY NOT COSTS
OF USAGE- AND- THE PEOPLE WHO
REGULATE UTILITIES ACROSS THE
WORLD OF HER STRUGGLED WITH THE
RIGHT WAY TO TRY TO. RECOVER
THESE INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS
ALONG WITH THE COST OF ACTUALLY
PRODUCING THE ELECTRICITY THE
PEOPLE ARE CONSUMING- AND IT
COMES DOWN TO IS ROSS MENTIONED
THIS BALANCE BETWEEN. TRYING TO
RECOVER SOME OF THE COST
THROUGH A MONTHLY SORT OF
SUBSCRIPTION FEE- THAT YOU PAY
JUST FOR CONNECTIVITY FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BASICALLY-
THAT'S ON- THAT'S NOT LINKED TO
THE AMOUNT OF ELECTRICITY
YOU'RE CONSUMING. AND THEN A
VARIABLE FEE PER UNIT OF ENERGY
ON TOP OF THAT I USED TO
DESCRIBE CELL PHONE PLANS TO MY
STUDENTS BUT NOW EVERYBODY GETS
FREE DATA ANYWAY SO IT'S LESS
INFORMATIVE- BUT IT'S NOT AN
UNUSUAL SORT OF COST STRUCTURE
IN A LOT OF KIND OF UTILITY
SETTINGS- NOW. IT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT. AMONG
PRACTICED IN CALIFORNIA A LARGE
REGULATED UTILITIES- RECOVER
ALL OF THEIR COSTS THROUGH A
VARIABLE FEE THERE IS A MINIMUM
BILL IT'S VERY MODEST- AND-
THAT PUTS MORE OF THE COST
BURDEN INTO THE VARIABLE FEE
AND THAT CONTRIBUTES TO HIGHER.
VARIABLE PRICES- THIS IS JUST A
COUPLE MAPS FROM WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES EVAN BOURNE STING
WORRIED AND SCRAPING ELECTRIC
RATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR
QUITE SOME TIME OFF THE WEB.
THE DARK THE TO HEAR THE HI THE
CHARGES AND ESSENTIALLY THIS IS
THE- FIXED CHARGE THE
SUBSCRIPTION FEE. PAID BY IF
YOU'RE CONNECTED TO UTILITY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY-
CALIFORNIA'S AT THE EXTREME
HERE OF HAVING IT'S ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BIT NEGATIVE BECAUSE YOU
GET THIS CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
REBATE WHEN YOU'RE CONNECTED TO
A- REGULATED UTILITY. IN
ADDITION TO NOT HAVING TO PAY A
MONTHLY FIXED FEE- SO THERE IS
THERE AREN'T COSTS BEING
RECOVERED TO THIS FEE AND THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO THIS PICTURE.
WHICH IS THE VARIABLE COMPONENT
OF THE PRICES- WHERE-
CALIFORNIA IS I SHOULD SAY
AMONG THE HIGHEST- I. WAS JUST
LOOKING AT THIS RHODE ISLAND
UNDER SOME METRICS COULD CLAIM
THAT THE CHAMPIONSHIP BELT HERE
BUT- CALIFORNIA MAY BE PASSING
THEM SOON. POINT WE HAVE VERY
HOT VARIABLE ACTRESS. IS FOR
MANY REASONS ONE OF WHICH IS
THE FACT THAT WE'RE NOT
RECOVERING ANY OF THESE
INTEREST COSTS THROUGH MY-
FIXED FEE. AND SO WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT PLUGGING A CAR
AND EVEY- INTO YOUR METER- IT'S
THIS PRICE YOU'RE GONNA PAY PER
KILOWATT HOUR AND THAT'S PART
OF THE CONCERN WE HAVE- ALL
RIGHT SO WHAT THE REACTIONS
I'VE GOTTEN ONE OF PRESENTED
THIS WORK. UP VERTICALLY FROM
THE VIRAL COMMUNITIES WELL
ISN'T IT THEY HAVE HIGH
ELECTRICITY PRICES IS NOT GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
WANT TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
USING ELECTRICITY. AND I GUESS
WE'VE GOT A BILL TO FAR WITH IT.
THIS IS. EFFICIENCY ENERGY IF.
TO YOU. THE ENTER KEY. WHY
EFFICIENTLY NOT THAT USE IT AT
ALL AND SO IF WE WANT TO THINK
THE SITE OF OUR HI GO THEN YOU
HAVE THAT WILL HOW HIGH IS TOO
HIGH THEN- AND ONE METRIC ONE
THAT THAT ECONOMIST SORT OF
EMBRACE IS THIS IDEA OF
COMPARING THE COST OF THE
TURNING ON A LOW FALL BELOW.
GOING IN YOU ELECTRIC ARE UP TO
THE COST ACTUALLY PUT RIDING
THE ELECTRICITY TO THAT
CONSUMER WHO IS GOING TO BE
USING IT- AND THIS IS A
COMBINATION OF THE COST OF
GENERATING ELECTRIC THE MARKET
GENERATE AND CAUGHT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDENT WE HAVE
BEEN THE SAME ISSUE ERICA THERE
SIR. IN ACOSTA INCLUDE. ANY
METRIC. AT THIS. REALLY
APPEALING ASK IN ITS EXCEPT
WHERE PRODUCING THE POWER THE
MORE ACOSTA SACK QUITE. IT'S
CAPITAL. SO THE OVERALL CAN HI.
BUT THINKING OVER. LANTS YOU A
LOT FRONT EXPENDED BUT ACT
PRODUCE THE ELECT. IS
ESSENTIALLY FREE ARM AND
THEREFORE WE DON'T ACTUALLY
WANT TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
USING IT ONCE WE'VE MADE THOSE
INVESTMENTS ABOUT OUR PRICING
STRUCTURE ISN'T. DOING THAT
IT'S ALSO CLEAN SO WE HAVE
ACTUALLY CHEAP TO PRODUCE CLEAN
ELECTRICITY BUT OUR PRICES
DON'T REALLY REFLECT THOSE
FACTS- OKAY SO THIS US ALARMING
MAP IT'S NOT A- IT'S NOT
POLITICAL. IT'S A- IT'S A MESS.
THE RELATIVE COST OF PROVIDING
THAT ELECTRICITY TO A CUSTOMER
AND SO THE DARKER THE BLUE HERE
BASICALLY THAT'S THE DEGREE TO
WHICH PRICES ARE TOO HIGH BY
OUR METRIC. THE DEGREE TO WHICH
THE VERY LOW PRICE EXCEEDS THE
COST TO BE A PROVIDING THAT
CUSTOMER WITH THE ELECTRICITY
AGAIN INCLUDING CARBON COST
LOCAL AIR POLLUTANT AND A FEW
OTHER- FEDERATION. NOW THERE
ARE PARTS OF THE- HE IS TO KEEP.
THE INS WITH THE LAW OF COAL
CREATING A LOT OF SOUL FOR THE
CAUSES DAMAGE FOR OTHER
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA IS NOT
ONE OF THOSE STATES- CALIFORNIA
IS A STATE WHERE PRICES ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH RELATIVE TO THE
COST OF PROVIDING INCREMENTAL
POWER TO THOSE STATES- NOW.
I'LL SO. ELECTRICITY WE STARTED
THIS CONVERSATION WITH THE GOAL
THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO SWITCH
PEOPLE FROM ALL. THOSE OTHER
SOURCES OF FUEL TO ELECTRICITY.
AND SO AGAIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES
HAVING MORE IN THIS IS WORK IN
PROGRESS WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
DO THE SAME EXERCISE FOR THE OF
FUELS. SO WE PROJECT ONE YOU
PROBABLY HAVEN'T HEARD THE
ANSWER ARGUABLY YES- THAT
GASOLINE WHEN YOU FACTOR IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS OF A
BURNING GASOLINE PARTICULARLY
IN SOME URBAN AREAS IS ARGUABLY
A LITTLE TOO CHEAP BOB
CERTAINLY RELATIVE TO
ELECTRICITY WHICH IS MASSIVELY
OVER PRICE- WE ARE AGAIN WORK
IN PROSPERED BY TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO FROM THE
UNDER PRICE TOOL TO THE PRICE
FUEL. THAT PASSES BETWEEN THE
STRUCTURE THAT THERE IS WELL
AND SO ARE MET AT LEAST A
LITTLE. BUT NOT NOT NEARLY AS
MUCH AS THE ELECTRIC SECTOR.
ALL RIGHT SO STEPS THAT COULD
HELP- GORY HEARD ACTUALLY MOST
OF THESE- POINT TO BE MADE- SO
ONE WOULD BE TO STOP ADDING.
CALL BUT THAT DID A TO BE DELAY
TO THE ELECTRIC SECTOR BUT ARE
NOT DIRECTLY ELATED TO THE
PRODUCTION OF ELECTRICITY. AND
ADDING THEM TO ELECTRIC BILLS
AND I THINK- OF WILDFIRE
RELATED COSTS ARE GOING TO BE
CERTAINLY THE BIG- THE TICKET
ITEM THAT WILL BE WILL BE
DEBATED GOING FORWARD HERE- BUT
THE OTHERS WE HEARD ABOUT
ENERGY EFFICIENT. GRAMS OUR
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT LOW
INCOME ENERGY CONSUMERS WHICH
ARE CERTAINLY WORTH WHILE DOING
BUT IT'S ALL WORTH ASKING
WHETHER THE SHOULD BE FUNDED
FROM ELECTRIC RATES THEMSELVES.
ARE OTHER WAYS TO TRY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THOSE TYPES
OF PROGRAMS. THEN THIS POINT IS
TO THE EXTENT WE CAN'T SHIFT
SOME OF THESE PUBLIC POLICY
COSTS ON TO OTHER REVENUE
SOURCES- TRY TO REDESIGN THE
TERRORISTS THEMSELVES IN WAYS
THAT BETTER ALIGN WITH THE COST
SENATE COURAGE PEOPLE TO USE
THE ELECTRICITY NGUYEN AND
WHERE. IT BRED IN BACK SHOW FOR
THEM TO DO SO AND THAT WOULD AS
ROSS SAID PROBABLY INVOLVED
RECOVERING AT THE A LITTLE MORE
THAN ZERO SUM COSTS FROM A-
MONTHLY FIXED CHARGE IF WE WERE.
BASICALLY A CARE VERSION OF A
MONTHLY FIXED CHARGE- TO TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS.
AND THEN LASTLY- AND- I THINK
ASSEMBLYMAN QUIRK STOLE SOME OF
MY THUNDER HERE- WEEK. THERE'S
AN ARGUMENT TO SUPPORT CLIMATE
POLICIES THAT THAT ARE
TARGETING REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS THAT MY TIME- BUT NOT
NOT NEARLY OVERLY STRICT IN THE
CHURCH A SET. OF UP UTILITIES
OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
TERMS OF DOING IT I THINK THE
THAT SOUL THE ROOF TAKE MEANT
ROOFTOP MAN IS IT IS AN EXIT.
WERE PUSHING LETTER G. TO
HONEST. BACK OUT IT SHOULD BE
THE ONE ALLOW FLICK. FOR
FINDING THE LOWEST COST WAYS OF
ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS RIGHT
THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LINDA
STARS OUT AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
IN THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
BUT I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING US HERE TODAY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING-
WE THINK IT'S VERY. IMPORTANT
TO AND GOOD TIMING A TO HAVE OF
THE DISCUSSION OF WHERE WE
FOCUS ON THE TRENDS THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN LIKE ELECTRIC ALL
ELECTRIC BILLS. I WANT
EMPHASIZE THAT I PRESSED TO
TODAY FOLK. EXCLUSIVE ON
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS RATES
BILLS- I ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
SOME. OF SOME KEY THEMES THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR IN THE
PRESENTATION. SO STARTING WITH
TWO. FIRST OF ALL SOME OF YOU
PROBABLY HEARD THE STATEMENT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE TRACKING
OR ON PARK OR ON PAR WITH THE
RATE OF INFLATION. AND THAT WAS
TRUE UP UNTIL SEVERAL YEARS AGO
AND THE THAT IS NOW THE RATES
ARE FAR OUTPACING THE RATE OF
INFLATION AND WE'LL SHOW YOU
DATE ON THAT. THING IS WHEN YOU
HEAR THAT STATEMENT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT RATES
ARE BEING REFERENCED WHEN THEY
SAY RATES ARE TRACKING WITH THE
RATE OF INFLATION. OTHERS
DIFFERENT DEFINING RATES SO
USUALLY WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
STATEMENT. THE STATEMENT IS
REFERRING TO SYSTEM AVERAGE
RATES AND SYSTEM AVERAGE RATES
ARE CUT THE COMBINED RATES ALL
THE CUSTOMER CLASSES FROM THE
LARGEST WHICH WHICH WOULD BE
THINK IT DOES COST. TO THE
SMALLEST VERSUS CUSTOMERS
REALLY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
DRILL DOWN DEEPER INTO CUSTOMER
CLASS SPECIFIC GRADES AND EVEN
BEYOND THAT YOU CAN GO FURTHER
BEYOND THAT IF YOU IF YOU TIME
AT THE END OF MY PRESENTATION I
CAN FOCUS ON. WHAT DRIVING LOW
LOW YOU CUSTOMER RATES AS WELL
WHICH A SUBSET OF RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. SO THE MORE
AGGREGATE THE RATE THE SYSTEM
AVERAGE RATE THE MORE THE
MASKING OF THE IMPACT ON
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS OF
INCREASED RATES. MOVING ON TO
SLIDE THREE. I WANT TO MENTION
THE PRIMARY DRIVERS TO THE RATE
INCREASES THAT WE'RE SEEING
FIRST THERE'S BEEN A STEADY
INCREASE IN REVENUE REQUIREMENT
UTILITIES ARE AUTHORIZED TO
CHARGE FOR CUSTOMERS REVENUE
REQUIREMENT IS JUST ANOTHER WAY
OF SAYING THE MONEY AT THE
UTILITIES. ARE AUTHORIZED TO
RECOVER FROM THEIR CUSTOMERS.
PUT ANOTHER WAY IT'S THE COST
THAT RATE PAYERS PAY FOR THEIR
SERVICE. SO WE'VE SEEN A STEADY
INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR OF
UTILITIES REVENUE REQUESTS. AND
WE HAVE SEEN ALSO OF THE A
DECLINE THIS IS THE SECOND
DRIVER A DECLINE SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN SALES VOLUMES. A AND
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS
BASICALLY THE ELECTRICITY SOLD
TO CUSTOMERS. UGH THE REASONS
FOR THAT ARE ARE GREAT
SUCCESSES IN ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AS WELL AS SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN ROOFTOP SOLAR. SO MOVING ON
TO SLIDE. FOR HERE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT SOME DATA OF I'M GONNA
PULL BACK AND LOOK AT SYSTEM
AVERAGE RATES AGAIN THESE ARE
COMBINED RATES OF WERE CAUGHT
THE LARGEST
BASICALLY TRACKING WITH THE
RATE OF INFLATION. OF ITS OWN
THIS TIME PARTICULARLY FOR P.
GINNY INDUSTRY GENIE THAT YOU
SEE SIGNIFICANT SALES DECLINES
PARTICULARLY FOR RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. ARE FROM RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS. YOU ALSO SEE THAT
EDISON SYSTEM AVERAGE RATE
TRACKS PRETTY MUCH ON PAR WITH
THE RATE OF INFLATION FOR NOW.
BEING TO SLIDE FIVE. HERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE RESIDENTIAL
SALES VOLUMES SIGNIFICANTLY
DECLINE AGAIN STARTING AROUND
TWENTY FOURTEEN FOR P. JEANNIE
AND SGD. AND YOU WILL SEE
DECLINE FOR EDISON SALES AROUND
TWENTY FIFTEEN AS YOU MAY BE
WONDERING BUT WHAT YOU JUST
SAID THAT'S THE SYSTEM AVERAGE
RATE FOR EDISON WAS TRACKING
WITH THE RATE INFLATION SO.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE THINK
THAT SO IS EVEN DESPITE THE
SALES DECLINE AS- AROUND THAT
TIME WE SAW EDISON TAKING SOME
SIGNIFICANT COST CUTTING
MEASURES. A WE SAW THAT
PRIMARILY IN THEIR GENERAL CASE
APPLICATIONS. THERE ARE SOME
OTHER THINGS TO THAT END OF
SUCH AS A REFUND SO THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO GIVE TO CUSTOMERS
TO THE SONGS. MOVING TO SLIDE.
SIX NOW WE'RE GOING TO GET EVEN
MORE SPECIFIC WE'RE LOOKING AT
OF THE RESIDENTIAL THE AVERAGE
RESIDENTIAL RATES. SO HERE
YOU'LL SEE US USING THESE
REPRESENTED BY THE REDLINE.
THEIR RATES OF INCREASE 57%
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE UP
THROUGH JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY. ONE REPRESENTS P.
GENIES RATES AND THE GREEN LINE
EDISON'S. AND AGAIN THE
DAUGHTER GRAY LINE IS THE RATE
OF INFLATION. SO JUST TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN REVENUES WHICH IS THE
MONEY THAT THE UTILITIES ARE
AUTHORIZED TO RECOVER FROM THE
CUSTOMERS. AND SALES WHICH IS
WHAT THE UTILITY BECAUSE IT'S
PAID FOR SERVICE. YOU TAKE THE
REVENUES YOU DIVIDE BY THE
SALES AND YOU GET THE AVERAGE
WAS INITIAL RIGHT. SO MOVING ON
TO SLIDE SEVEN. YOU MAY BE
WONDERING WHERE IT'S GOING. END
THIS GRAPH SPECIFICALLY FOCUSES
ON MESSAGING NEEDS RESIDENTIAL
RATES. WITH ANY FORECAST YOU
HAVE TO MAKE ASSUMPTIONS SO
WHEN WE DID THIS FORECAST OF
VEGGIES RATES WE ASSUME THAT
EVERY. PENDING REQUEST THAT
THEY HAVE BEFORE THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN APPROVED THERE'S BEEN
NO ADJUSTMENTS TO THOSE
REQUESTS. AND YOU'LL SEE THAT
THE GRAY LINE REPRESENTS THE
HISTORIC RATE. STARTING FROM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE YELLOW PART
REPRESENTS THE FORECAST. AND
THE OTHER PART IS A COMBINATION
OF THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED AND ARE GOING TO GO
INTO A FACT. AS A. TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
THOSE THINGS ARE AGAIN PENDING.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THEIR RATE IS
FORECAST TO FAR OUTPACE THE
RATE OF INFLATION. I FOR
COMPARISON SAKE THE GREAT
DOTTED LINE HERE- WE TOOK THE
RATE OF INFLATION AND JUST
ESCALATED SEEKING SEE FOR SAKE
THE RATE WOULD BE IF IT WAS
JUST ESCALATED FOR INFLATION.
MOVING TO SLIDE EIGHT THIS IS A
FORECAST OF P. GENIES
RESIDENTIAL RATES. AGAIN THE
GRAY LINE REPRESENTS THE
HISTORIC RATE AND THE YELLOW
LINE IS A FORECAST. THE YELLOW
LINE ASSUMES THAT P. GENIES
MOST RECENT GENERATE CASE
REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED NO
ADJUSTMENTS. AND MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT SLIDE. THIS IS OUR
FOCUS OF EDISON'S AVERAGE
RESIDENTIAL RATE. YOU RECALL
THAT EDISON'S RATE WAS TRACKING
WITH INFLATION BOTH SYSTEM
AVERAGE AND RESIDENTIAL. OUR
FORECAST HOWEVER SHOWS THAT
NOPE THERE COULD BE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WE FACTORED IN THEIR
MOST RECENT GENERATE CASE
REQUEST OF OVER TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH THEY
FILED IN NOVEMBER. THIS ASSUMES
THAT A- THAT RECALL. IS. SO
CLEARLY OF EDISON'S RATE IS NOT
WE DON'T FORECASTED CONTINUING
TO TRACK WITH THE RATE OF
INFLATION GET THE RATE OF
INFLATION. SLIDE TEN SO I
UNDERSTAND RATES ARE RATES BUT
CUSTOMERS CARE ABOUT THEIR
BILLS WHAT THEY ACTUALLY PAY.
THIS CHART SHOWS STDS RESIDENT
RESIDENTIAL BILLS WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN PAYING AT WHAT WE FOR
CUSTOM TO PAY. AGAIN ANY FORK
OUT WITH ANY FORECAST YOU HAVE
TO MAKE. CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS.
SO WE ASSUME FIRST OF ALL THIS
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE BILL'S OF
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS. ALSO THE
TWENTY TWENTY DID A POINT ON IS
A FORECAST OF REVENUES AND
SALES. ED WE ASSUME CONSTANT
USAGE WHICH MEANS THAT WE DON'T
WE AVERAGE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WINTER AND SUMMER
RATES. OF AND CLIMATE ZONES. SO
YOU'LL SEE THE BLUE LINE
REPRESENTS AS TEACHING NEEDS
COASTAL ZONE. FOR QUALITY SOUND.
THE ORANGE LINE IS OUR INLAND
ZONE WHICH INCLUDES PLACES LIKE
FALLBROOK CHULA VISTA. AND THE
RED LIGHT PRESENTS A MOUNTAIN
SO WHICH INCLUDES PALOMAR AND
CAMPBELL. OUR FORECAST SHOWS
THAT. REGARDLESS OF CLIMATE SO
CUSTOMERS COULD SEE AS MUCH OF
A 38% INCREASE IN THEIR BILLS
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT
THROUGHOUT THE NEXT FEW SLIDES
IS REGARDLESS THE CLIMATE SO WE
ARE SEEING SIGNAL TICKET BILL
INCREASES. THING TO DO SLIDE
ELEVEN FOCUSING ON TEACHING
RESIDENTIAL BILLS. AGAIN THIS
IS NOT INCLUDE THE BILL'S OF
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS. THE BLUE
LINE THE BOTTOM LINE.
REPRESENTS THE COMMUNITIES
EUREKA SAN FRANCISCO SAN LUIS
OBISPO. THE ORANGE LINE UKIAH
SAN JOSE THE MORE MODERATE
ZONES. AND THE REDLINE. IS THE
HOTTEST AREA AND TEACHING
SERVICE TERRITORY CENTRAL
VALLEY. BASED ON OUR FORECAST
WE COULD SEE AS MUCH AS A 46%
INCREASE ACROSS THE CLIMATE
ZONES. MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
SLIDE. SIR FORECAST OF EDISON'S
RESIDENTIAL BILLS. AGAIN THE
BLUE LINE IS THE COASTAL
COMMUNITY OR COLORS OWN
INCLUDING ORANGE IN SANTA
BARBARA. ORANGE IS THE MODERATE
STONE FROM CLEANING VENTURA.
AND THE RED LINE REPRESENTS THE
HOTTEST SO INCLUDING SAN
BERNARDINO. EDISON'S CUSTOMERS
COULD SEE AS MUCH AS A FIFTY
NINE PERCENT INCREASE ACROSS
CLIMATE ZONES. I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS JUST A
FOCUS ON ELECTRICITY RATES.
THAT IT DOES NOT FACTOR IN
NATURAL GAS RATES WHERE WE ALSO
HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT INCREASES.
AS AN EXAMPLE FOR PGD
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS NATURAL
GAS CUSTOMERS. BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY WE'VE SEEN A 15%
INCREASE IN THE RATES. SO NOW.
WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO. WHAT THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS
DOING IS WE ARE TRACKING THESE
INCREASES AND WE ARE TRYING TO
TRACK THE POTENTIAL INCREASES
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS WE
DEVELOPED A TWO. OUR COMPUTER
MODEL. THAT WILL HELP DECISION
MAKERS SEE THE IMPACT OF
POTENTIAL RATE AND BILL
INCREASES. SO WHENEVER YOU TO
ATTY CME TO THE COMMISSION AND
ASKED FOR MORE RIGHT HERE
FUNDING. YOU CAN INPUT FROM
NATION INTO OUR COMPUTER MODEL
AND SEE WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD
BE. THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THESE
KINDS OF REQUESTS THAT COME IN
A DAY AT THE COMMISSION. AND
IT'S HARD TO SEE. PACKED ONE
OFF. IT'S BETTER TO SEE THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THOSE OF
THOSE REQUESTS SO THAT DECISION
MAKERS CAN PRIORITIZE THE
DECISIONS AND SEE WHAT IMPACT
THERE WILL BE ON CUSTOMERS. THE
TOOL IS GOING THROUGH THE
VETTING PROCESS OF WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE COMMISSION
STAFF ON IMPLEMENTING THE TOOL.
ON A MAKING IT TRANSFORMATION
TRANSPARENT TO THE PUBLIC.
WE'RE HOPING THAT OTHER
UTILITIES WILL ASSIST IN USING
THE TOOL AND THAT EVERY TIME
THEY FILE AN APPLICATION OF THE
COMMISSION REQUESTING REPAIR
FUNDING BILL RUN THE NUMBERS
THROUGH THE- MODEL OR- A
SIMILAR ONE. AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION. SO WITH THAT I'LL
I'LL STOP THERE. WELL THANK YOU
OUT MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERSSO- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE INVITATION MY NAME
SCOTT CRATER ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CUSTOMER SERVICES
FOR ST YOU GAS ELECTRIC AND I
HEARD TODAY THIS IS A REALLY
TIMELY DISCUSSION AND YOU KNOW.
WHAT DID ANY ARMED NO WE
PROVIDE A VERY UNIQUE SERVICE-
TO RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
REALIZE THAT TRANSIT GAP THIS
IS JUST LIKE WATER IS A LITTLE
LIFE TO CENTRAL PARK CONDOM AND
SO WHAT TO. MAKE WE ARE STATE
SOME BARBELL GOAL WHAT THIS
TIME ART REALLY KEEPING IN LINE
THAT YOU CAN AND THAT THIS CAN
HAPPEN OR SWEAR SINCE FOR
HERBAL CUSTOM. THANK YOU VERY.
THE THIS DISCUSSION. I'M SKIP
OVER DISSONANT OF TIME TO
RECOVER QUITE A BIT IN JUST F
THE FREE OF WHERE WE'RE IN
TERMS OF WHERE THE RATES IN THE
BILLS ARE FOR THE VERY SHE TOLD
EASE- I'LL SAY AT THE ALL THERE
ARE A RATES ARE HIGHER THEN I
WON'T NEED THE DECK. ARE OUR
RATES ARE HIGHER THAN WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE THEM TO BE AND WE'VE
CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT ABOUT ON
THE INCREASES THAT WE'VE SEEN-
BUT LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT SOME THE TUBES TAX IT
REALLY IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW THE
INVEST. MEETING G. JANET. DOES
COME ONE OF THE CLEANEST. YOU
TO. IN AMERICA. 45% OF OUR
ENERGY COMES FROM RENEWABLES-
THAT SPECIALLY THE EARLY YEARS
OF THE OUR PS THAT CERTAINLY.
UP COSTS MORE. ABOUT WE'RE
REALLY PROUD OF THE STEPS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN- TO DELIVER MORE
CLEAN ENERGY TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN NAMED THE MOST
RELIABLE ELECTRIC UTILITY IN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS IN A ROW. SO YOU
KNOW OUR OUR CUSTOMERS WANT TO
HAVE RELIABLE POWER AND WE'VE
DEVELOPED A SYSTEM. AND A
DELIVERY MECHANISM- THAT MAKE
SURE THAT- WE CAN BE- THE BEST
IN THE WEST UNITED STATES
BETTER FACTORED NAMED. THE MOST
RELIABLE UTILITY IN AMERICA. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND I THINK
OF. ALL THE- MEMBERS ARE WHAT
OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE
MADE IN TERMS OF WILD FIRE
AFETY- OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS- SO THAT TO HELP KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. SO I AM GONNA
COVER JUST BRIEFLY SOME OF THE
NEIGHBORS WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
IT NOW. I AND BLAH IN A BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE BRING
IT DOWN TO KIND OF A REAL
UTILITY LEVEL- AND I WOULD SAY
THERE'S REALLY FOR- PRIMARY
DRIVERS OF WHY WE'RE SEEING.
HIGHER RATES AND ULTIMATELY
HIGHER BILLS YOU'VE HEARD IT.
SALES ARE DECLINING YOU KNOW SO
FOR US ARE OVERALL SALES NOT
JUST RESIDENTIAL ARE DOWN ABOUT
14% SINCE SINCE TWENTY TWELVE.
AND THAT AGAIN THAT IS
VIRTUALLY. TO THE SUCCESS STATE
WE'RE SEEING LESS GOODUSAGE
BECAUSE OF ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND A MASSIVE MASSIVE
INCREASING AMOUNT OF SOLAR
POWER- SPECIALLY IN THE SAN
DIEGO REGION. HOPE IS THAT AS
WE BEGIN TO SEE MORE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES COME ONLINE- WE DO WE
WILL SEE YOU KNOW SEE MORE
LECTURE VACATION DOWN THE LINE
THAT WE CAN GET. A START TO
STABILIZE THE SALESMAN THAT
WOULD COULD HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON ITS- CERTAINLY GOOD
EFFORT THE- SMITH. AND YOU KNOW
THIS IS THE PIE. YOUR DOCTOR
WILL. IN THIS CASE BUT THE
WIRES WE USE TO DELAY ELECT.
FOR CUSTOMERS YOU KNOW WHAT HE-
KEEPS SO LOT. OF YEARS UPPER BG.
VESTED ONE POINT FIVE. DOLLARS
AS IN YOU FIRE SAFE PROGRAM IN
ORDER PROTECT OUR CUSTOMER FROM
CALLOUS. ALL THOSE ARE
INVESTMENT THAT RISK I THINK
THE- THERE WERE. IN TO WE CAN
NEXT TO SEE INVEST IN A FEW TO
KEEPER COMMUNITIES. WHAT NUMBER
THREE REALLY POLICY MANDATES SO
THIS IS A FAIRLY LARGE BUCKET
THAT INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD- LOW INCOME PROGRAMS
ENERGY EFFICIENCY S. CHIP- YOU
KNOW ALL YOUR MOST OF THEM AT
LEAST I WE THINK ARE REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAMS.
ASPECTS YEAR LOW INCOME
PROGRAMS- IN TAKING AND TAKEN
AS KIND OF A SINGULAR PROGRAM
IT SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE BUT WHEN
YOU START TO ADD ALL THESE
TOGETHER. WE ACTUALLY ESTIMATE
THAT ABOUT 22% OF OUR ELECTRIC
RATE IS MANDATES AND SO IT IS
BECOMING A- A BIGGER CHUNK OF.
OF OUR OVERALL RATE OUTLOOK.
FINALLY IN THE MORE BILLS SO WE
AGAIN WE TALK A LOT ABOUT RATES
IN THE END A CUSTOMER SEES A
BILL. LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF HOW
WHAT IS THE TOTAL THAT I OWED
ES DE GENIE IN A GIVEN MONTH. I
TALKED WHAT'S OF MURDERS.
BETTER ISSUE THE NOT PAY. PAY
BILLS. WE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE STARTING TO SEE IS
THE EFFECTS OF CHANGE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT YOU KNOW
HERE IN THE STATE AND CERTAINLY
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS HOTTER LONGER AND
MORE INTENSE SUMMERS IN SAN
DIEGO THIS INCLUDES OUR COASTAL
REGIONS. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE EXPERIENCE THE SIX
HOTTEST WEEKS WE'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED IN SAN DIEGO AND
THAT'S HOUSING MORE ELECTRICITY
DEMAND. REGION AND AGAIN IT'S
NOT JUST- IN ONE CUSTOMERS THAT
IS ALSO STARTING TO AFFECT OUR
OUR MORE TEMPERATE CLIMATE-
COASTAL CUSTOMERS AS WELL AND
SO THIS IS BECOMING- A TRUE
IMPACT CLIMATE IS BECOMING A
TRUE IMPACT ON ACTUAL ENERGY
BILLS. SO THAT THOSE ARE KIND
OF THE DRIVERS TO LET ME TALK
ABOUT JUST LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SOME POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS ONCE A
VERY SPECIFIC POLICY AND THEN-
MAYBE THREE TRENDS THAT FOR AT
THAT FOR YOU TO CONSIDER. I YOU
KNOW WHAT WE THAT PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT IMMEDIATE
TERM ACTIONS THAT WE COULD
TAKE. IT PERFORMING THAT ENERGY
METERING POLICY THAT SO THIS IS
THE SUBSIDY- THAT WE PAY TO. TO
SOLAR OWNERS NOW. LET ME BE
CLEAR FROM THE GET GO IS THAT
ESTROGEN STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF
OUR CUSTOMERS. ADDING SOLAR BUT
TO THEIR HOMES- MATTER FACT
WE'VE GOT ABOUT 13% OF OUR
CUSTOMERS TODAY THAT ABOUT
SOLAR AND THAT SO THAT IS A
MASSIVE INCREASE. IN THE AMOUNT
OF SOLAR IN SAN DIEGO. BUT WHAT
IT IS DOING IS THAT IS SHIFTING
BECAUSE THOSE FOR CUSTOMERS FOR
AVOIDING COSTS. YOUR VOIDING
HAVING TO PAY FOR THE GRID
WE'RE SEEING NOW AN ESTIMATED
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. OF COSTS THAT
ARE BEING SHIFTED FROM OUR
SOLAR CUSTOMERS. FOR NON SORT
CUSTOMERS. OKAY SO WE DO WANT
TO BALANCE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE FAIR AND EQUITABLE
ENERGY POLICY THAT BALANCES THE
NEED TO WE WANT MORE SOLAR. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT HELPS
DRIVE DOWN CHICHI THAT HELPS US
WITH OUR CLIMATE GOALS BUT
THERE IS AN EQUITY ISSUE
BECAUSE WHAT IS OCCURRING AS I
THINK ABOUT OUR- YOU KNOW OUR
FAMILIES IN EL CAJON INLAND
VERY HOT AREA YOU KNOW IF. WE
HAVE FOUR MAYBE MAKE SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND
AFFORD SOLAR DOESN'T HAVE THE
MEANS TO PUT SOLAR ON THEIR
HOMES THEY'RE NOW PAYING A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT- PENALTY. ON
THEIR ENERGY. FOR POOR FLUENT.
TO BE ABLE TO PUT SALT ON THEIR
HOMES. OKAY SO AGAIN AS POLICY
MAKERS WERE GONNA NEED TO
BALANCE. THE YOU KNOW THIS
ISSUE OF EQUITY. WITH THE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL A PROGRESS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT IS
COMPLETELY AN EQUITABLE. IN IN
TERMS OF THAT ENERGY METER
POLICY NEAR THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION DID MAKES
VERY VERY MINOR TWEAKS AND IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BUT-
EXPECTING TO HAVE A MORE
FUNDAMENTAL REFORM OF NET
ENERGY METERING IS SUPPOSED TO
BE KICKED OFF IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THAT SITTING HAS NOT
STARTED YET OUR AND CERTAINLY
NUMBER FORM WAS A COMPONENT OF
AB THREE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WAS
THE LAST. COULD BE ENERGY-
ENERGY RATE RESTRUCTURING BILL
BACK AND TWENTY THIRTEEN SO
THAT'S KIND OF A VERY. SPECIFIC
POLICY THAT WE THINK ADDRESS
IMMEDIATELY LONGER TERM WE
REALLY NEED TO START HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT
RESTRUCTURING HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL RESTRUCTURING OF
RATES AND HOW WE PRICE
ELECTRICITY IN THE STATE- YOU
KNOW I WOULD YOU KNOW WE STILL
COULD HAVE TO THOUGHT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN. MY OF HOW DEVELOP
RATES FOR THERE ARE SOME PENS
THAT WE KEEP IN MY MIND AS WE
THINK ABOUT RATE NINE RATE
STRUCTURES AND ULTIMATELY THAT
AFFECTS. CUSTER PERSONAL. ABOUT
IT TODAY ELECTRIFICATION SO
TODAY CHARGING VOLUME POLICE OF
ME WITHOUT YOU KNOW EACH
CUSTOMER PAYS FOR KILL HOUR OF
THAT THEY USE SOME HOURS OF THE
DAY OUR CUSTOMERS COULD PAY
FIFTY OR SIXTY CENTS A KILOWATT
HOUR OKAY AND IF AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE TRYING TO. IT IT'LL
CLASS FAMILIES BECAUSE FAMILY
THROUGHOUT CANDY A GO TO SWITCH
TO HAVE TO KEEP THESE IN THE
GARAGE HAVES THE ELECTRIC SPACE
HEATING AT THE LEDUC WATER
HEATING ELECTRIC COOKING. AT
THOSE PRICES IT'S ON AFFORDABLE
AND SO WE REALLY NEED TO START
HAVING A REAL FUNDAMENTAL-
DISCUSSION ABOUT COMPLETELY
RESTRUCTURING HOW WE PRICE
ELECTRICITY. NUMBER TWO. IS NOT
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION
NOW LET ME BE CLEAR WE ARE
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF OUR
CUSTOMERS- GOING COMMUNITIES
SEGREGATION WE GOT GREAT
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE CCA'S.
NDA AND BURKE THERE TO HELP
MAKE THEM SUCCESSFUL. AS YOU
THINK ABOUT BILLS THOUGH THE
ENERGY BILLS CUSTOMER SEES- AS
MORE OF OUR CUSTOMERS MOVE OVER
TO CCA'S WE THINK THE VAST
MAJORITY WILL BE CCA'S IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AT THAT POINT SB
JEANNIE ONLY CONTROLS ABOUT
5260% OF THE ENERGY BILL. SO
THE REST OF THE DECISIONS ON
WHAT GOES INTO THAT BILL WILL
BE MADE BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NOT S. D. GMD AND SO AS WE
THINK ABOUT PRICING AND WE
THINK ABOUT HOW WE STRUCTURE
RATES THA'S A REALLY
FUNDAMENTAL IMPORTANT. THING
THAT WE'VE GOT IT WE'VE TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT WE WILL CONTROL
ALL BILL. AND THEN FINALLY IS
REALLY AROUND TECHNOLOGY SO WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT SOLAR WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THE SAME-
GROWTH CURVE IN TERMS OF
STORAGE. SO AGAIN SO NOW WE'VE
GOT YOU KNOW SUBSIDIES FOR
SOLAR. YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY YOU
KNOW SUBSIDIES FOR STORAGE MORE
OF OUR FLUENT CUSTOMERS GOING
TO BE A BEEN SOLVED BOTH OF
THOSE. ALLERGY ORDERED REDUCE.
MOUNT ENERGY THAT THEY FROM THE
GREAT AND WHAT'S- PAYING LESS
FOR THE GRID RESOURCE. ACTUALLY
THERE ON STAND BY THEM. AT THAT
POINT MORE YOU KNOW OUR LOOK
LESS OF WHAT CUSTOMERS ARE
THOSE CUSTOMERS WHO CANNOT
INSTALL SOLAR AND STORAGE THEY
ARE GOING TO BE PAYING HIGHER
AND HIGHER RATES SO AGAIN AS
POLICY MAKERS IT'S- REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY
CONSIDERED BOTH THE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL- CONSIDERATIONS
AS WELL AS THE- EQUITY
CONSIDERATION SELF TAUGHT WITH
THAT. THERE TO LOOK AT YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SHOULD ALL
OF YOU A SURE AND ON THE VERY
IMPORTANT. AND OF ALL TURN MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE IT IT HAS AS YOU
WERE PRESENTING I HAVE THAT
THAT SENSE OF YOU KNOW FOR
EVERY. NO ONE STEP FORWARD
THERE WE TAKE WE'RE TAKING TWO
STEPS BACK AND SO IT'S- SORT OF
THIS HOW DO WE GET TO THE PLACE
WHERE WE ARE ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
DURING THE RESPONSE SAYING. AS
WE SEE CALIFORNIA MOVING OUT
VERY AGGRESSIVELY AND SETTING
GOALS AND IT'S OUR PS AND- ARE
WORKING HARD TO GET THERE
CERTAINLY BY TWENTY THIRTY
SALUTE TALENTS IN AFTER THAT
BUT YOUR MAP THE DESCRIBED. THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY DOCTOR. OF
A SMELL- SHOWS THAT THE RATES
ARE LOWER BUT THE RELY MORE ON.
ALSO FUELS AND SAID. SO I GUESS
I AM PART OF MY- QUESTION I
pTIPPING POINT ON PRICES AND-
ARE WE WERE OR ARE WE ARE THIS
SIDE TIPPING. AND THE COST
VERSE. THE GHG PROGRAM AND HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO- CERTAINLY
ADDRESS IT INCIDENT THE SECTORS
WHERE IT'S CERTAINLY MOST
INTENSE LIKE AND
TRANSPORTATION. ARE WE GET INTO
A TIPPING POINT. THANK. YEAH I
I'M I'M I WE RISK WE RISK GOING
BEYOND IT WE MAY BE WE MAY BE
BEYOND THE TIPPING POINT I
GUESS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SORT
OF TIP PEOPLE BACK INTO A
DIRECTION THAT THEY'VE NEVER
BEEN IN TERMS OF CERTAINLY
ELECTRIFY TRANSPORTATION AND-
HOME HE AND- WATER HEATING. AND
MAYBE WE CAN STILL DO IT BUT IT
SURE IS A LOT HARDER WHEN THE-
PRICES ARE AS MISALIGNED AS
WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN DISCUSSING-
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE HEARD
IMPLIES THAT THAT SITUATION IS
PROBABLY GONNA GET WORSE
UNLESS- WE START. SERIOUSLY
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE ROOT
CAUSES OF WHERE THAT
MISALIGNMENT CAME FROM- I THINK
IT AS WE DE CARBON EYES- BATES.
IT IS PUTTING PRESSURE ON
ELECTRICITY PRICES BUT IT'S NOT
NEARLY THE SOLE SOURCE OF IT
ESPECIALLY IF WE COULD DO THE
D. CARBONIZATION AND- IN IS
EFFICIENT WAY POSSIBLE- I THINK
A LOT OF IT IS A BUNCH OF OTHER
SORT OF POLICY CHOICES THAT
GONNA WITH THAT THE COPS. CAN
DROP WE PUT PRESSURE ON PRICES.
JUST ONE ROQUE- THOUGHT- AND-
MISS RADIUS- TOUCHED ON IT
EARLIER WHEN. THE PRESIDENT PC
WAS HERE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND-
REMINDED US THAT THE WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS AND THOSE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT FOR
EVERY. BILLION DOLLARS OF COST
THE RATES GO UP BY 7% AGAIN IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE FOR EVERY GOOD
THING THEY WERE TRYING TO DO AN
APPROPRIATE AS WE'VE BEEN HIT
VERY HARD BY THESE WILDFIRES
AND UTILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN.
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COSTS AND
NEEDING TO DO UPGRADES IN ART
IN THE GRID THESE ARE ALL VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS CLEARING OUT.
AROUND THEIR UTILITY POLES-
TECHNOLOGY A LOT OF WITH SEND
IT TO HAS- A SHOWN THAT THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO. HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
ALL OF THIS WORK I MEAN IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE TO REACT WE
HAVE TO DO THE RIGHT THING- WE
HAVE TO MAINTAIN IT DESCRIBED
EARLIER IN TERMS OF MEETING OUR
GOALS. I'M I KNOW YOU IN SOME
OTHER SUGGESTION SOME SPOOKY
SOLUTIONS THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF OUR
POLICY BUT GIVE US SOME
ADDITIONAL THOUGHT SHE MIGHT
HAVE ON HOW WE MIGHT. FILTER
YEAH- SOME OF THESE IDEAS GOING
FORWARD YEAH- WELL. THE SHERMAN
THE EFFORTS FALLS RELATES TO A
WILDFIRE SPENDING YOU KNOW WE
WOULD RESULT VIEW THOSE DOLLARS
IS BEING ADDED ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL AND I AND I THINK
THAT AS WE'VE SEEN AND-
ESPECIALLY WITH SAN DIEGO ONE
BEING A RELATIVELY SMALL
UTILITY COMPARED TO SUCH. AS AN
IN GINNY'S SO A BILLION AND A
HALF DOLLARS OF WHAT FIRE
SAFETY INVESTMENT FOR US. IS
VERY VERY SUBSTANTIAL AND WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT WORK HAVE-
YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL- IN
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
MADE DO YOU VIEW THOSE AS- THE
CLIPPER THING IF WE IN WOULD
LIKE BEING A LIVER ELECTRICITY
OPERATOR CYST. PLEA IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE PROUD OF
THOSE DOLLARS EVEN DID AND WE
THINK THAT WE NEED MORE. THAT
YOU IN PERSON THE TRUCKS CAN OF
STORY MUSIC FOR THE SYSTEM.
PLEASE AND SEE IN ON PARTS
WHERE WE START TO DIVERT FROM
THE OTHER YOU TO YOU. PART
BECAUSE WE BEEN MISTER. BASSMAN
OUR OUR BIG COMPONENT IT YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF. THIS YOU KNOW
DOCTOR BUSHNELL YOU KNOW OF
TRYING PUT MORE. YOU KNOW. THE
EIGHT IN THE END USER
INVESTMENTS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE IT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HAVE A MECHANISM TO COLLECT
THOSE DOLLARS SOMEHOW. AND
REALLY IT'S JUST FROM A POLICY
MECHANISM IT'S HOW ARE WE GOING
TO COLLECT THOSE DOLLARS AND
THOSE ARE CHOICES THAT WE MAKE
THROUGH A RATE CASE IS.
SOMETIMES TO THE LEGISLATURE
SOMETIMES TO GO THROUGH- OTHER
MECHANISMS OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION- BUT IF WE
CAN GET AWAY FROM HAVE BEEN
MORE OF OUR COSTS VOLUMETRIC
CHARGES BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU. THAT OUR CUSTOMERS DON'T
LIKE HIGH BILLS WILL TO THE
THING THAT THE- MORE. AND THAT
IS UNEXPECTED HIGH BILLS. AND
WHAT IS HER. IS SPECIALLY AS
WE'VE SEEN. THAT YET- GET
HOTTER SUMMERS IS THAT IT'S
THOSE UNEXPECTED HIGH BILLS.
THE ND THAT JULY AUGUST
SEPTEMBER TIME FRAME WHERE THEY
HAD TO RUN YOUR AIR CONDITIONER
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY BECAUSE
HUMIDITY WAS HIGH. IT WAS
NINETY DEGREES HOME. AND WE
HAVE ALL OVER COSTS AND DOUBLE
METRO GREAT SO THIS. THEN IT'S
KIND OF LIKE YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE YOU KNOW YOU DID MENTION
CELLPHONE SO YOU'RE PAYINGBY
THE GIGA BYTE BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH WATCHING A VIDEO ON
FLICKS. ACTUALLY COSTS OKAY
WHAT'S THE SAME THING FOR IF
YOU PUT OUR CUSTOMER HAD ON IS
THIS THE SAME THING FOR
CUSTOMERS TO THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE REAL GOOD AWARENESS OF HOW
MUCH IT COSTS. TO RUN YOUR AIR
CONDITIONER TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY BUT IF YOU GOT TWO KIDS AT
HOME AND THEY'RE A COMFORTABLE
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT. AND SO
IF WE CAN PUT MORE COSTS MAKE A
MORE FIXED TO BETTER PREDICT
BUILDING LESS BILLABLE FORTY
FOR CUSTOMERS YOU'RE GOOD TO
HAVE. BETTER CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE OVER THANK YOU. IN A-
THIS CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU CAN FOR THE
PRESS I WANNA GO TO YOUR
COMMENT ON THAT MAKE ME DURING
AND INEQUITY SO CAN YOU PUT A
NUMBER IN TERMS OF- WHAT IS THE
AVERAGE COST TO AN AVERAGE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY WHEN IT COMES
TO- SUBSIDIZING IN MANY WAYS.
FAMILIES THAT ARE A BIT MORE
AFFLUENT THAT HAVE SOLAR PANELS
THAT ARE IN FOR THE GRID SO
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE OR ONE
FAMILY IN PARTICULAR AND THEN
WHAT IS THE ADDED SOME ACROSS
THE STATE SO WE ACTUALLY
ESTIMATE THIS IS A BROAD
ESTIMATE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR. NO FOR US PRESS
IN. RUMORS IF. FOR JUST
PRESTIGE. SELF EVERYONE OF OUR
NON CUSTOM THEY'RE PAYING ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE A YEAR.
TWO ONE FOUR TWO TWO HUNDRED.
SUFFOLK EFFECT FOLLOW UP I DO I
JUST WANT TO GET A MICROPHONE
OVER YES I THINK SO THE HOUSE
OF GET CLOSER THERE WE GO CHECK
ONE TO GET OKAY. SO I WANT TO
GET A PERSPECTIVE NOT JUST FOR
YOUR CUSTOMERS BUT FOR EVERYONE
THAT'S HERE THAT'S LISTED RIGHT
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA IF THE
AVERAGE IS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
A YEAR EXTRA THAT FAMILY
SUBSIDIZING A MORE AFFLUENT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT FOR THEIR
SOLAR NOT PAYING INTO THE GRID.
IF WE WERE TO ADD UP SOME. ALL
OF THE CUSTOMERS ACROSS THE
STATE. WHAT IS WHAT DOES THAT
NUMBER LOOK LIKE. I DON'T I
DON'T I DON'T PERSONALLY HAVE
THAT NUMBER BUT I KNOW THAT WE
COULD THAT WE YOU KNOW WE TALK
TO THE OTHER UTILITIES AND FOR
THAT WE COULD NOT RESPOND BACK
TO YOU WITH THAT WITH. THE
ISSUE OF INEQUITY ISRAEL AND I
THINK IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR
US TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT. HOW WE
HELP AND HOW WE ACTUALLY WORK
ON LEGISLATION THAT. SOLVE THE
ISSUE OF AN EQUITY OR A- OR
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS IT. ACROSS
THE STATE THANK SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IS. IS IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. UNINCORPORATED EAST
LA. AND SO THAT'S MY THAT'S
RIGHT COME FROM MY PURSE. BUT
I'M THINKING ABOUT IT IN TERMS
OF JUST. BUT IS A LOOK LIKE FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE AND WHY HAVE
WE- IN THE LEGISLATURE ALLOWED
FOR THAT INEQUITY FOR TO HAPPEN
FOR SO LONG. AND SO HOW DO WE
FIX IT HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT.
IS WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN. YEAH
WE CAN WE CAN CERTAINLY RESPOND
BACK TO YOU. I LOOK I MEAN THAT
IS THE REASON WHY. ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY
STATEWIDE. SELL FASTER AND-
LIKE ELECTRICITY HEY WE GOTTA
GET YOU GET GOOD STAFF
YOURSELF- IT LOOK I MEAN YOU
YOU PUT IN A SUBSIDY LIKE NAM
FOR A REASON WE WANTED TO KICK
START THE INDUSTRY WE WANTED TO
ENCOURAGE ADOPTION AND IT'S
WORKED YOU KNOW IT'S WORKED AT
ME WE ARE SEEING CONTINUED
GROWTH IN WITHIN THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY AND WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT BUT NOW IT THE
TIME LIKE THAT FOR STATE.
STARTING TO AT. PERFORMING
DOING AWAY WITH THE ELIMINATING
CHANGING- THIS NET ENERGY
METERING POLICY AND WE THINK
IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LOOK AS WELL SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR AND
REEMPHASIZE AND JUST BASED ON
NOT QUICK DATA THAT YOU JUST
RECEIVED. THERE IS
APPROXIMATELY TWO DOLLARS HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
THAT ARE SUBSIDIZING THOSE THAT
ALREADY HAVE SOLAR POWER AND
THEY'RE NOT PAYING THEIR FIR
SHARE AND GREAT THAT RIGHT THAT
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU.
EXACTLY WHAT I SAID. I AM AND
IT MAKES IT EVEN WORSE THAT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION IS NOW
TELLING PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEW
HOMES WE'RE CERTAINLY ABOVE
AVERAGE AND THEY'RE ABLE TO BUY
A HOME AT ALL PROBABLY IN THE
TOP FEW PER EARNERS THEY'RE
GOING TO GET MORE OF THOSE
SUBSIDIES BECAUSE THE DEMANDING
THAT THEY PUT ON ROOFTOPS SO.
THIS IS COURSE ALSO RATING THE
COST TO THE HOUSING- WHICH IS A
VERY BAD THING GIVEN THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD MORE OF IT. AND.
IT IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE WHAT I WANTED TO. ASK
THE RATE THE YOU'RE NO LONGER
RATE PAYER ADVOCATES YOU THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATES- HAVE YOU AS
PUBLIC ADVOCATES ARE TAKEN LOOK
AT THIS ISSUE- OF THE- ENERGY
COMMISSION. WELL FIRST OF ALL
WE'VE ALREADY AGREED WE'RE
GOING 2100% RENEWABLES SO WHAT
QUESTION IS DO WE DO WITH THE
MOST EXPENSIVE WAY WHICH IS
ROOF TOP SELLER OR LESS
EXPENSIVE WAYS SUCH AS OFFSHORE
WIND. SOLAR FARMS IN PARTICULAR
WHICH IS SEVERAL TIMES CHEAPER-
HAS THE- OUR PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE LOOKED AT THIS AND- HAVE
THEY TALKED WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ABOUT THESE
UNNECESSARY- COST THEY'RE
PUTTING ON RATE PAYERS. WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE COSTS OF ROOFTOP
SOLAR AND THE ENERGY MEETING
SPECIFICALLY AND THE ISSUES RUN
COST SHIFTING OF WE WERE
LOOKING FORWARD VERY MUCH TO
THE PC'S REVISIT OF THE ISSUE
OF I CAN TELL YOU WE ARE
ACTIVELY AS WE SPEAK WE HAVE A
TEAM OF ANALYSTS. TRYING TO
COME UP WITH OPTIONS AND HOW TO
DEAL WITH THAT COST BURDEN OKAY
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S MANDATE TO MAKE
THE SITUATION EVEN WORSE. HI
YOU HAVE OU TALKED WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ABOUT. REALLY
YOU SHOULD BE MORE CAREFUL
ABOUT THE COSTS THAT YOU PUT ON
CUSTOMERS. WITH WE HAVE NOT
DONE THAT THE WELL I THINK YOU
SHOULD I THINK THAT'S PART OF
YOUR- MANDATE. ARM THAT YOU ARE
THE ADVOCATES FOR THE RATE
PAYERS AND THIS HELPS NO ONE
EXCEPT THE FEW PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD TO BUY NEW HOMES TODAY.
NEW SO FAMILY HOMES THE TOP FEW
PERCENT OF EARNERS AND I JUST
DON'T THAT APPROPRIATE WAY AN
APPROACH POLICY. THEOTHER
POLICY AND PERHAPS DOCTOR BUSH
NOW ONLY ALL YOU CAN SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS. ARM
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU YOU'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE PEOPLE DOING
THIS RESEARCH AND YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS.
THAT WE HAVE FOUND THAT. THE
MONEY WE'RE SPENDING ON ENERGY
CONSERVATION. OUR IS NOT PAYING
OFF IN THE WAY THE CALCULATIONS
TALUS. THIS PROBABLY HAS TO DO
WITH THE FACT THAT AN
UNINSULATED BUILDING IS SIMPLY
A BETTER INSULATOR THAN WE
THINK SO WHEN YOU ADD IN THE
NATION IT MAKES LESS OF A
DIFFERENCE THAT'S AT LEAST ONE
OF THE THEORIES. UP BUT
CERTAINLY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
WORK BY THE M. I. T. YOU SEE-
CHICAGO GROUP ON THIS LOOKING
AT MID WESTERN STATES BUT WE
ALSO HAVEINFORMATION ARE OUT
LOOKING AT FOLLOW UP HERE TO
THE WORK WE'RE DOING. WHERE THE
COST OF GAS EXCUSE ME THE
REDUCTIONS IN GAS USAGE OR TWO
OR THREE TIMES LESS THAN WE
EXPECT. OUR ELECTRICITY. HAVE
YOU HAVE YOU TAKEN A LOOK AT
THIS. SO I AM NOT ONE OF THE-
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE THOSE
STUDIES I AM CERTAINLY FAMILIAR
WITH THEM- AND THE AYE THE
STUDY TO REFERRING TO THERE'S A
GENERAL SORT OF SET OF ATTEMPTS
TO TRY TO DO THINGS LIKE
RANDOMIZED CONTROL TRIALS
AROUND ENERGIZED AGENCY
PROGRAMS TO TRY TO. TO MEASURE
THE IMPACT AND A BIT MORE
RIGOROUS WAY AND THE GENERAL
THEME RESULTS IS BEEN LESS
EFFECTIVE THAN WHAT THE OF
STAND ENGINEERING ESTIMATES
GOING IN WITH EXPECT AND SOME
IS A LOT LESS EFFECTIVE- IT
DOES. THE CALL- THIS DISCUSSION
TO THOSE COSTS ARE ALSO IN THE
VARIABLE COMPONENT OF RATES AS
WELL TO PAY FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
ALIENS A YEAR AND- AND AGAIN
THERE ARE- THESE ARE COSTS THAT
ARE NOT- CONTRIBUTED TO NEARLY
AS MUCH BY SOLAR HOMES FOR
EXAMPLE- BECAUSE OF THOSE COSTS
BEING PART OF THE VARIABLE RATE
COMPONENTS. SO ITS THEY'RE
THEY'RE ALL SORTS OF ELEMENTS
OF COST SHIFTS GOING ON WITHIN
JUST FUNDING FOR THOSE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS I THINK. SINCE ABOUT
EXACTLY HOW MUCH SHOULD BE
APPROACHED THE IMPLEMENTING
THOSE PROGRAMS AND IS ALSO REAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD
TRY TO FUND THE PROGRAM IS ALL
AT LEAST THE ONES THAT WE THINK
ARE. ARE AFFECTED. YEAH SO NOT
ALL. I REMEMBER I HAD WORK DONE
ON MY OWN HOME AND THEY TOLD ME
TO ADD MORE INSULATION FOR MY
TO MY CEILING WHEN I HEARD
ALREADY OUR THIRTY SIX ARE THEY
TOLD ME TO PUT INSULATION
UNDERNEATH MY HOME WHEN THE
HOME WAS ALREADY WELL INSULATED
FROM WIND AND- HAVE THE
FURNISHED DOWN THERE IT'S
DIRECT. AND TO SO I PUT IN
PLACE SHOULD UNDER HOW SUB INTO
MORE IN THE US BASICALLY I GOT
NO- ENERGY SAVINGS- AND- THAT
WAS VERY DISTURBING TO ME AND I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY HAPPENING
A LOT. NOW GET PEOPLE HAVE DATA
WHICH CONSERVATION EFFORTS HAVE
THE BIGGEST PAY OFFS I KNOW
BERKELEY HAS LOOKED AT THIS AND
THEY CAN TELL YOU- WHICH
WEAPONS ARE MOST EFFECTIVE
WHICH ONES ARE LEAKED EFFECT
OF. AND I THAT IS THIS IS IN A
AREA AGAIN FOR THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATES TO LOOK. THAT WE
OUGHT TO BE SPENDING MONEY ON
THE THINGS THAT WORK AND NOT
MONEY ON THE THINGS THAT DON'T
WORK. I YES I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH YOU AND WE DO DO
THAT WORK IN TERMS OF. WHEN E
SEE. PROPOSALS COME IN THE DOOR
THE PC. AND WE ACTUALLY MONITOR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALREADY UNDER WAY RT BEING.
SUPPORTED BUT WITH A PAIR
FUNDING WE ARE TRACKING THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF THOSE
PROGRAMS WHICH INCLUDES ARE
THOSE PROGRAMS WORKING ARE THEY
DEMONSTRATING REAL BENEFITS TO
THE PUBLIC AND TO RATEPAYERS
AND THERE'S A LOT OF. IT OUT
THERE FRANKLY RIGHT THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT THAT ARE NOT COST
EFFECTIVE THEY'RE NOT EFFECTIVE
OVERALL. HAVE YOU LOOKED
SPECIFICALLY AT SOME OF THE
ENERGY CONSERVATION PROGRAM WE
HAVE LOOKED WE HAVE AN ARE
LOOKING AT ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SPECIFICALLY AND WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THERE. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU. AND IF I MAY THE ONE
OTHER- MAP THAT I DIDN'T
INCLUDE IN MY PRESENTATION THAT
IS A BIT FRUSTRATING IS THAT
THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY EFFICIENCY
EXPENDITURE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IS HIGHLY CONCENTRATED ON THE
COASTS WHERE EXACTLY THE PLACES
WHERE THE PRICES ARE. MAY
EXTREMELY OVER PRICED- WHICH IS
PROBABLY THE LAST PLACE YOU
WANT TO BE TRYING TO SUBSIDIZE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AS OPPOSED AS
PARTS OF MIDDLE OF THE CALL
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S VERY TRUE
BECAUSE IT'S THE PEOPLE ON THE
COAST WHO CAN AFFORD. TO ADD
THE INSULATION AT CETERA AND
YES THAT WAS ALSO ONE OF THE
FINDINGS. WHEN WE LOOKED AROUND
PROGRAM UP FINAL THING IS. TALK
ABOUT FIXED COSTS. NOW I COULD
ARGUE HAVE THIS HUGE VERY
EXPENSIVE ON BUT I'M USING LEDS
IN ITS NEW BE. ARM BILL SO I AM
USING. MAYBE EVEN LESS
ELECTRICITY THAN A MUCH SMALLER
AND YET. WE IT'S VERY IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY HARD TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO A FIXED COST
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND
EVERYBODY GETS THE SAME LINE
COMING OUT HOUSE IS BEING
EVERYBODY WHO HAS A LINE
WHETHER IT'S- COUPLE. SQUARE
FOOT TINY HAPS OR A FOUR
THOUSAND- HOW SOME OF THESE-
SIXTY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
MANSIONS. THEY HAVE A LINE
COMING OUT TO THEIR HOUSE IN
THE CASE OF SIXTY THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT MANSION THEY MIGHT
HAVE US A BIGGER LINED BUT- BY
AND LARGE BETWEEN THE FOUR
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOUSE THE
FOUR HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT HOUSE.
THE GONNA GET THE SAME LINE.
YET IT DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE JUST BECAUSE OF
EQUITY CONCERNS THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE SAME THING CHARGE. ON
THE OTHER HAND THE PERSON WITH
THE FOUR THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
HOUSE THAT'S MORE RECENT BELT
AND THEREFORE AND- IT'S MORE
FISH. WITH THEM A LADY'S
FREEWARE IT SAT AROUND. ARM MAY
PASS COOLEY. TERMS PASSIVE ET.
ARE THEY MY NOT BE THAT MUCH
MORE THAN THE SMALLER. SO CAN I.
DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS. ANYONE
HERE KNOW THOSE HOW TO DO A
FIXED PRICE IN EQUITY WAY ARE
FIX CHARGING EQUITABLE WAY THEY
SHOULD SPEAK UP. I DON'T. HAVE
A SOLUTION I DO WANT TO AGREE
WITH YOUR OBSERVATIONS- AND I
ALSO THINK THAT THEY APPLY TO
LOW USAGE CUSTOMERS. IN THAT
FIGHT- SO I THINK YOU'RE ASKING
THE SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLAR
QUESTION AND ULTIMATELY IF YOU
ASK ANYBODY IN THE INDUSTRY WHO
WORKS IN THIS SPACE YOU'RE
GONNA GET. ON TEN TEN DIFFERENT
ANSWERS- BUT WE DO AGREE WITH
YOU THAT- IF YOU LOOK KIND OF
OUT INTO THE FUTURE AND AT THE
SIDE MY COMMENTS EARLIER
AROUND- NOT JUST MAYBE A
SPECIFIC FIX CHARGE BUT REALLY
MOVING MORE. ENERGY PRICING IS
KIND OF A FIX SUBSCRIPTION
BASIS. WHERE YOU COULD DESIGN
RATES IN A WAY THAT TAKES THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION WHETHER IT'S
BY. A AUDIT CAPACITY BASIS
MEANING HOW MUCH ENERGY ARE YOU
ACTUALLY SUING- IN YOUR HOME
COULD YOU- COULD YOU SCALE UP
BASED UPON YOU THE SIZE YOUR
HOME OR YOU KNOW DON'T. ENERGY
USAGE COULD YOU RESET THAT
EVERY YEAR BASED UPON HOW MUCH
YOU USE AND COULD YOU ALSO HAVE
MEANS TESTED SO MEANING WE
STILL HAVE WE STILL COULD PUT
IN PLACE- DISCOUNTS FOR OUR LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS AS WELL SO. I
THINK IT MAY. SEE YOU TAPE
SCRIPT SHIN KICKS LIKE ME BUT
ALL IN A- HE ANY POP THAT ONE
TO. YOU KNOW CORD. CUSTOM WELL
BUT AGAIN THE RICH GUY WITH
CELL IS FOR NAY EVEN ELECT.
BILL RIGHT WELL YOU HAVE ONE
BUT DON'T PAY VERY MUCH YOU
COULD NOT BEAR AGAIN THAT WOULD
ASSUME YOU'RE ALSO REFORMING
THAT ENERGY METERING AND YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT KIND OF THE
TRUE CONSUMPTION OF THE HOME.
AND NOT JUST HOW UNIT NETTING
OUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE PAYING US TO JENNY
AND WHAT YOU'RE GENERATING
WITHIN YOUR PANELS. DID YOU
HAVE ANOTHER COMMENT. FOR
PUBLIC ADVOCATE SIDE TOO I JUST
WANT TO I WANT TO BE CAREFUL
NOT TO LOOK AT FIX CHARGES AS A
PANACEA OF FOR HIGH RATES OF
AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO A COMMENT
I MADE EARLIER ABOUT LOOKING AT
CUSTOMERS BILLS AND THE CONCERN
THAT THAT YOU YOU EXPRESSED OF
DOVETAILS WITH ANOTHER CONCERN
WHICH IS WHEN I SAY LOW USAGE
CUSTOMERS I'M TALKING ABOUT
CUSTOMERS WHO USE BELOW AT AT
THE BASE LINE. LOWER QUANTITY
UP ELECTRICITY THAT THEY COULD
BE HIT WITH HIGH FIXED. CHARGES
SEE HOW TO BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT HOW YOU STRUCTURE
SOETHING LIKE THAT. RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A MINIMUM BILL TO TAKE
CARE OF THE SITUATION WHERE A
CUSTOMER PAYS. A MODEST MINIMUM
BILL OF FOR A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
ENERGY. WE THINK THAT. THAT IS
A BETTER WAY TO GO AND IT
DOESN'T PENALIZE LOW USAGE
CUSTOMERS THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME IF NOT I'M GOING TO TURN
TO THE PUBLIC IF OUR PANELISTS
CAN JUST REMAIN WHERE YOU ARE
WILL. TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT- AND
THEN WE'LL TURN BACK TO MEMBERS
IF THEY HAVE ANY OTHER THOUGHT
THAT THEY'D LIKE TO SHARE AT
THAT TIME SO WILL. WELCOME
THOSE WHO WERE. I WANTED TO
SHARE A THOUGHT. GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE TWO MINUTES AT THE MOST.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES CESSATION
ONE I THINK THAT CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING. WE AGREE WITH THAT
ELECTRIC AFFORDABILITY IN
CONJUNCTION WITH RELIABILITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY IS REALLY
CRITICAL I WAS MENTIONED IN THE
LA AS WE ARE BY MISTER BROWN
THAT WAS DISCUSSED HERE THAT
ELECTRICITY PRICES IF THEY'RE
HIGHER COULD BE A BARRIER TO
FUTURE GHG REDUCTIONS WE
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THAT
CONCLUSION. THE GOVERNOR
RECENTLY HE SAID HIMSELF THAT.
ELECTRICITY IS THE ARCHITECTURE
OF TRANSFORMING THE
TRANSPORTATION FLEET WHERE 41%
OF THE MISSIONS ARE SO
CERTAINLY WE THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT RATES FOR HIS
BILL. TEAMMATES PERSPECTIVE WE
THINK RATES AND BILLS MATTER AT
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND ECONOMICALLY
DIVERSE STATE- ARBORS BE A
FORTY FIVE MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND YOU KNOW WHERE IT ONE
STATE AT A BILL MIGHT BE LEFT
ANOTHER PART OF THIS MY BEHIND
SO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT. EIGHT
BILLS TOGETHER I DON'T THINK WE
CAN THEM IN SILOS. I AM JUST IT
AND NOW IT'S JUST ABOUT. WAS
THAT IT TODAY WAS ON I OWE YOU
BATES JUST WANT TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE. FOR THE MUNICIPAL AS
WELL- BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
YOU RESIDENTIAL RATES ROSE BY
27% WHICH FAR OUTPACED THE
RISING Q. U. RATES NATIONWIDE-
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BASED ON
AVERAGES APPEAR YOU RESIDENTIAL
BILLS TWENTY WAS NINETY TWO
DOLLARS. BUT NATIONALLY THE
AVERAGE BILL WITH SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS TO SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
IN CALIFORNIA. DESPITE THE RISE
IN RATES. USE THAT HAVE- A 15%
LOWER THAN I OWE YOU RATE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP THEM LAW BUT
THE TO. LA JUST MANDATE IS IN
TRANSMISSION ACCESS ANOTHER
PRESSURE. ABOUT AND WE NEED TO
SEE. CAUGHT SIZE ALSO THE
ELECTRIC SECTORS ON AND RIGHT I
THINK THE TOUCH. BETWEEN TWENTY
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN GHG
REDUCTIONS FROM THE MISSION
SECTOR 30% TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR EMISSIONS ACTUALLY ROSE
5% DURING THAT TIME. AND WE
THINK ELECTRIC SECTOR WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAD EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND ALSO HELP
ACHIEVE REDUCTIONS IN OTHER
SECTORS LIKE TRANSPORTATION BUT
AFFORDABILITY MUST REMAIN FRONT
AND CENTER WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS. AND
MAINTAINING PLANNING
FLEXIBILITY IS FOR UTILITIES TO
THE CONTINUE TO CONSIDER
DIFFERENT OPTIONS TO RESOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS A FOR
TODAY'S TO REALLY PREPARE TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON GERALD AND ALEX
JACKSON WITH AN RTC I AM ONE OF
THOSE ENVIRONMENTALISTS TODAY
DR BUSHNELL'S POINT BUT I AGREE
THAT THE ELECTRICITY PRICES ARE
TOO DARN HIGH TODAY AND SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF THIS COMMITTEE
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
HAMPERED PERHAPS SIGNIFICANTLY
IN OUR ABILITY TO ELECTRIFY
MORE AND USES IF WE MAKE THE
PRICE OF ELECTRICITY
PROHIBITIVELY EXENSIVE AT THE
SAME TIME. WILDFIRES IS MAKING
IT LESS RELY SO WE KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE THE NUMBER ONE REASON
PEOPLE BUY ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
THE FUEL COST SAVINGS RELATIVE
TO GASOLINE- SO AGAIN IF TO
PRESENT TRENDS CONTINUE WE SEE
REAL APPAREL FOR OUR
ELECTRIFICATION AGENDA- AGREE
WITH ALL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU FOR TODAY- SHOULD BE LOOKED
TO TAKE THINGS OUT OF THE RATE
BASE THAT DON'T REALLY HAVE TO
BE A READ EITHER. PROGRAMS WITH
ON THE STATE BUDGET. AND SIR.
I'M DIGGING A HOLE NOT MAKE IT
IN WORSE BUT- I ONE HUNDRED
WHAT WE SEE IS A REAL. MOVING
FORWARD IN THE EXPLODING COSTS
POTENTIALLY IN RATES AND THAT
IS FIRE MITIGATION. AS YOU
NOTED EVERY BILLION DOLLARS
FROM P. GENIES EXPERIENCES- 7%
BILL INCREASE. THEY RECENTLY
FILED THEIR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS PROPOSING TO
SPEND. SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS SO DO THE MATH
AND THAT'S COMPLETELY NOT
SUSTAINABLE UNDER TRADITIONAL.
RATE MAKING SO WE REALLY WANT
ENCOURAGED THIS BOBBY TO THINK
ABOUT HOW CAN WE FINANCE.
SYSTEM HARDENING USED. FOR SAVE
LIABILITY. OUTSIDE OF LET
GRADES. THROUGH OTHER SOURCES
OR OTHER WAYS OF NANCY DOESN'T.
IMPACT NOW THIS BILL SWEEPING
TO ELECTRICITY AND ARE CLEAN
AND RELIABLE ENERGY SOURCE. AND
I'LL TO LEAVE YOU WITH SOME OF.
YOU COULD THINK ABOUT YOU NEED
TO CONVINCE YOU THIS MR HOLE
BUT I. AFTER EVERYONE THAT WE
COULD. ABOUT WAYS TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT IN OUR WESTERN GRIP-
WE THINK WE'VE SEEN THE-
DEMONSTRATED SAVINGS FROM THE
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET THE
SAVINGS THAT PROVIDES TO
CUSTOMERS WE- CONTINUE TO THINK
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO LOOK AT
THOSE INTEGRATION SOLUTIONS AS
WE LOOK AT. HIGHER RISK POOL OF
PRETTY. EDUCATION STATE. BUT
THE OTHER ONE. LEAVE YOU WITH
IS THE FLIP SIDE OF THIS
DYSTOPIAN FUTURE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE LETTING.
CLIMATE NEWS WILDFIRES MAKE OUR
LOOKS. MORE PENSIVE LESS
RELIABLE MEANS OF THE CARLO
TING. POSITIVE STORY THE MORE
WE AND BETTER ACTUALLY. AND
VEHICLE. IS A PUTS DOWN
PRESSURE ON RATES FOR EVERYBODY
AND WE JUST PUT A STUDY OUT.
THE ELECTRICITY JOURNAL THE
LOOK AT P. GINNY SERVICE
TERRITORY. IF THEY DID SMART
OCCASION AND THEIR SERVICE
TERRITORY THEY COULD REDUCE.
COST IMPACT FROM WILDFIRE. 28%
DOWN TO NINE PERCENT. SO THESE
ARE THINGS WE NEED TO MAKE
HAPPEN WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
ENABLE EDUCATION BOTH AS A
CARBON STRATEGY AND IS
AFFORDABILITY STRATEGY THANK.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS-
IT'S COME TO OUR IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT LEGISLATION
IS GOING TO BE RE INTRODUCED
THIS YEAR THAT WOULD AUTHORIZE
A RATE PAYER FUNDED HARPER BEN
OF THE FAILING EAGLECREST
STORAGE PROJECT. KRESS SPELL
OUT THEY KNOW AGAIN IT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE TO FORCE
CALIFORNIANS TO PURCHASE THIS
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT THAT SAY EXPERTS
HAVEN'T FOUND TO BE NEEDED FOR
A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE REMOVING
THAT ABILITY TO CONSIDER THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND OPTIONS
TO HAVING ALREADY KNEW JIM. WAS
AGAINST BUT WE ARE TODAY WHICH
FIVE JUSTICE AND CLIMATE
JUSTICE. IT MATTERS WORSE THIS
PROJECT EAGLE CRAP IS AN AND
RIGHT ARE MENTAL DISASTER WHICH
WOULD PROPOSED TO OVERDRAFT
DESERT AQUIFER THE TO JOSHUA
TREE NATIONAL PARK. VERY
SIMILAR TO THE CAN PROJECT AND
AS WE HEARD TODAY REPAIRS ARE
FEELING IT- IF WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE CHOICES TO INCREASE RATES
LET'S MAKE THOSE CHOICES THAT
ARE GUIDED BY FACT NEED. AND
NOT POLITICS AND CORPORATE
BAILOUTS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND ONLY SERVER WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE- TO BUILD
ON MELISSA'S COMMENTS. WE ALSO
BELIEVE IT IS IRRESPONSIBLE POP
CITY OF PREFERENCE MOST
EXPENSIVE ENVIRONMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTALLYDAMAGING
PROPOSAL. GUARDING PASSED AS WE
LOOK TOWARDS ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY. CALIFORNIANS PAY A
LOT MORE THAN THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN CONSUMER ON ENERGY AND
THIS EAGLE CREST BELT
LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE WE PAY
EVEN MORE. WE ARE STILL FIGURE
OUT THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
WHILE. THIS IS A RESPONSE FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED. MAKES PRETTY COMMENTS ON
BEHALF THEIR CLOTHES THANK YOU.
MARK TONY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TURNED THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK. FIX CHARGES ARE NOT
THE ANSWER TO THE ENORMOUS RATE
INCREASES THAT ARE ON THE TABLE.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON HAS
THE GENERAL RATE CASE PROPOSAL
THAT WHEN ADDED TO OTHER
PROPOSALS CURRENTLY ON THE
TABLE BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
BECAUSE THE MONTHLY INCREASE OF
FORTY THREE DOLLARS A MONTH
WITH FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
YEAR. THOSE TYPE OF THINGS ARE
NOT GOING TO BE FALL OF.
SHIFTED IN THROUGH THROUGH FIX
CHARGES OKAY THAT'S ONE SECOND
THING IT YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE FROM
ACTION TO MODERATE THESE RATE
INCREASES ONE IS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD THIS I HAD TO
STOP PATH BAR. THAT MAN.
EXPENSIVE EITHER BATTERY FOR S.
CHIP MICRO PALM STORY THERE ARE
SO PROPOSALS OVER AND OVER AND
ONE THAT I'M PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT IS TRAPPED
TATIAN A TRAFFIC. OKAY BECAUSE
BECAUSE- REALLY SUGGEST THAT
THE PROPER PLACE FOR REVENUE
FOR EVEY CHARGING STATIONS REST
IN THE TRANSPORTATION FACTOR
NOT THE ELECTRIC FACT OF
ALREADY PAID SO MUCH. ANOTHER
CONCRETE. IT WHY SHOULD RATE
PAYER SUBSIDIZED GAS LINE
EXTENSIONS FOR NEW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT OKAY A LOT CLIMATE
CHANGE PROPOSAL COST RATE
PAYERS MONEY HERE'S ONE THAT
FAVORITE. ME MAKE RATE EARTH
PAY FOR LINE A THANK VERY MUCH
THANK. GOOD AFTERNOON MY TWO
CENTS AS THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION- I REALLY
APPRECIATED WE REALLY
APPRECIATED THE DISCUSSION
TODAY AND I WOULD JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT IN THE
CONVERSATION. OR DOUBLE RICKETS
THAT INDUSTRY WELL AS WELL AS
COMMERCIAL RATES ALSO BE
DISCUSSED- AS MANUFACTURERS WE
ARE HIGH ENERGY USERS I CAN
ONLY DO SO MUCH TO DO OUR USAGE
WITHOUT IT INNER PRODUCTION
THIS IS CONCERNING TO HAVE
COMPACT. IN OUR RENTAL LOSS
GOOD PAYING JOBS HEARING HEALTH.
PRODUCTION GOALS. WE ENCOURAGE
THE CAN TO KEEP THIS IN MIND AS
A LEGISLATIVE YUR CONTINUES
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT EXAMINING
WAYS WE CAN LOWER RATES HAS
BEEN MENTIONED BEFORE LASTLY
ALL ADVOCATES CONVERSATION IS
EVEN MORE CRITICAL IN MIND OF
POWER AND LIGHT UP SHUT OFF WE
ARE TIRED ACOSTA IT'S AS WE'RE
ALSO NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
FOUR DIGIT OF OPERATE IT'S
IMPROVE STATE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON- NEIL TO SIDE WITH
THE NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION. PUBLIC ADVOCATE
OFFICE HAD THIS NICE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT SAID BAD
WORSE AND LET ME TELL YOU A
QUICK STORY THAT GOES FROM BAD
TO BAD TO WORSE AND THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY A FEW PEOPLE
BEFORE ME WHICH IS PROPOSED.
STORAGE EAGLECREST PROJECT
WHICH ARE FOR IT THE PARENT
THAT THERE EIGHT NOW ALLEGES
ARE GOING TO BE HEARING A
PROPOSAL TO ALL OF US. TO PER.
IN SOME SAID I. FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT THAT THE X. OF
SAYS NOT EVEN THE SOME P. ARE
TALKING ABOUT OKAY ABOUT THE
TRUE COST THE TRUTH THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE CHOICES THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE DEAL WITH
RISING ENERGY COSTS. WHAT ABOUT.
WHY WE BE THINKING ABOUT ME. I
TO PAY FIVE. DOLLARS THAT IS
NOT EVEN NEEDED INSULT ME TALK
ABOUT SOME THE MECHANICS HERE I
MEAN PART PART OF THE REASON
THAT. LET ME JUST INTERRUPT YOU
FOR A SECOND AND I'M GONNA LET
YOU FINISH YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
BUT WE'RE MOP. EVERY BILL THAT.
THAT'S A BILL IS. BRIBED SHOULD
ONE FORWARD THAN ON YOU'RE
SPEND THE TIME TO. DO A WE HAVE
TO DO TO. THE ABOUT IT IT'S. SO
YOU CAN USE YOUR ROOM IN A FEW
HIGHLIGHTED A IN PARTICULAR
WESTERN APPRECIATE THE CALL
BECAUSE WE ARE TO ABOUT AND
CERTAINLY AS WE'VE TALKED NOT
SPUR AS YOU OF THESE MAY THAT
WILL. KURTZ SAVE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS NOT SEEN BILL.
THERE'S NO BEEN WHAT INTRODUCED
ALIGNS WITH YOURS AND OTHERS CA
AND WE'RE GONNA JUDGE UNTIL ONE
IS IF DAY GET PRESENTED. A BUT
WE DO THINK THAT IN THE CON OF
A WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT
OVERALL. OF HOW THESE MANDATES
MAY AND ON COSTS THAT SIR PRO
THING YOU CHAIR APPS THAT'S
THAT'S WHY MANY OF US ARE HERE
YOU KNOW THESE ARE SOME CHOICES
SOME REAL CHOI IS AN I THINK.
IT TO BE IT OUR CELL PHONE
RIGHT NEED TO. PURCELL ARE AND
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A HISTORIC
PAUL IN FROM THE THAT PEOPLE
BEEN LOOKING AT. ON THIS
SOMETHING WITHIN THIS CON. OUR
MEN'S ON JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND- I'M- FROM ALL THE EXPERTS
HERE. TAKE YOUR PRE YOUR
COMMENTS ON. THE COURT.
COMMITTED TO A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS TO WORK ON THAT- WE
COULD. YOU KNOW TAKE MORE BUT
THEN WE'D HAVE TO REDUCE THINGS
LIKE HIGH SPEED RAIL AND-
TRANSIT AND OTHER MONIES COME
FROM IT. BUT THAT IS ONE OPTION.
THEN I'D LIKE THE COURT STORAGE
NOW. CARE ABOUT HOW WE DO OUR
STORY BUT WE CANNOT GET TO A
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY WITHOUT
STORAGE THERE IS SIMPLY NO WAY
IN THE WINTER TIME WE JUST
DON'T GET THE SOLAR YOU NEED
SEASONAL STORAGE THAT CANNOT BE
DONE WITH BATTERY IT WOULD TAKE
MORE IN THE WORLD I SEE. BUT
CAN TO A HUNDRED TIMES MORE
LITHIUM AND COBALT THEN WE HAVE
TO MAKE THE BATTERIES AND THEN
THE BATTERIES WOULDN'T BE VERY
EFFICIENT BECAUSE WITH
BATTERIES YOU GET SELF JUST
CHARGE. ARE YOU WORKING EITHER
GOING TO NEED TO HAVE A LOT
MORE PUMP STORAGE OR HYDROGEN
STORAGE WHICH IS FRANKLY AN
AREA I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
EXPLORED UP BUT WE'RE GONNA
NEED STORAGE AND DON'T TELL ME
WE STORE NOW MAYBE THIS OF
PROJECT IS NOT A GOOD PROJECT
FINE BUT WE NEED A HELL OF A
LOT OF STORAGE WHICH BY THE WAY
WILL COST MONEY AND IT'S ONLY
GOING TO. FROM RATE PAYERS ARE
AND I THINK AGAIN OUR TARGET I
DON'T SEE A WAY AROUND IT. YOU
OF A MANILA TO OTHER MAY OF THE
ANY CLOSING THOUGHTS OR
COMMENTS OR ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO POSE BEFORE WE
WRAP UP THIS HEARING- NOT SEEN
SEEN ON I'M JUST GOING TO SAY
TO OUR OUR PANELISTS WE DO
APPRECIATE ONCE AGAIN YOUR
MISSION. WORK THAT YOU'VE IN
THE SIDE IN THE STUDY IN THE
ANALYSIS OFROUND RATES IN THE
IMPACT THAT. PROJECTS AND OTHER
FACTORS- HAVE ON. THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY AND TO OUR REPAIRS
IN THE STATE AND WE'RE MINDFUL
OF THAT- AND AS YOU POINTED OUT
IT IS A DIFFICULT BALANCE- BUT
IS IT THIS IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY THIS COMMITTEE-
TO. FIND THAT BALANCE AND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP IN MIND. OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE PUBLICLY BUT
ALSO YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND
THERE MAY BE TIMES ON THE WAY
MAY WILL TO VISIT THIS ISSUE.
CERTAINLY AS THE- SOME OF THE
SUGGEST BEEN PROPOSED WRIST. OF
RATES AND WHAT IT MIGHT LOOK
LIKE AND HOW WE MIGHT I'M NOT
SO- WE WILL. ARE YOU SURE. AND
IN THAT IS A LONG WAY TO GET.
OF THE CLAY. HOW MIGHT WANT TO
PURSUE BUT WANT TO THANK FOR
BEING TODAY. AND IF THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.